Record lại trên máy anh đi.
Anh nên tắt đi và anh record máy anh cho
nó chắc chắn. Hôm trước em cũng bị vậy
đó.
>> Tại vì hồi nãy có một bạn nào đang bấm.
Ok.
Ok. Ok. Anh cũng đang bấm record ở trên
máy của anh rồi. Ok.
Ồ anh phải chắc chắn nha, chắc chắn là
anh đang record trên máy anh nha.
>> Em đừng làm anh anh anh rói chứ.
Ok rồi được rồi.
>> Hỏi đi Minh cuối zom chị gửi cho.
>> À ok. Vậy là chị Hương
>> bữa
à chị bỏ cái con Fantom nó tự
>> Ô chị Hương ơi vậy là cái record của em
hôm trước nằm trên chị hả?
Không có là của chị riêng còn em còn em
record thì em ở đâu thì cũng ấy rồi đấy.
Nếu mà em muốn cái buổi cái tiên hôm
trước cũng có người record cho em sao em
tìm không thấy được á. Chị
>> thử ti giúp em.
>> Muốn không chị? Chị đang định hỏi
>> đó. Đó đó đó. Vậy là được rồi. Ok quá
tốt rồi. Sau buổi này là liên hệ với chị
Hương nhé.
>> Chơi chứ không chơi đ
>> rồi. Ok. Thôi mình chắc cũng xin phép
bắt đầu được rồi. Tại vì cũng để nãy giờ
cũng còn số anh chị chắc vào sau thì
mình cứ tính sau thôi.
Ok. À xin cảm ơn cả nhà. À thì cái buổi
tối hôm nay cũng là một buổi giao lưu
thôi chứ cũng không phải là buổi
dạy hay là về kiến thức đào tạo gì gọi
là hàng lâm lắm. Cho nên nếu mà có cái
phần nào mà chưa được chỉnh chu trao
chuốt thì cũng mong cả nhà thông cảm bỏ
qua nhé. Thì lời đầu tiên là Minh xin
chân thành cảm ơn cả nhà đã có mặt ở cái
buổi Zoom hôm nay. Thì Minh cũng xin
giới thiệu sơ qua à Minh á thì chắc có
lẽ bạn bè hay là mọi người ở đây cũng đã
biết sơ lược qua các cộng đồng, qua các
Zoom rồi ha thì cũng thích chia sẻ về
công nghệ, cũng thích chia sẻ về AI và
các ứng dụng AI trong ứng dụng trong
cuộc sống hay là trong công việc vân
vân. Thì nếu có cơ hội thì rất mong là
anh em bạn bè có thể là giao lưu với
nhau qua các nền tảng như Zalo, Facebook
vân vân. à mình lại cộng tác và chia sẻ
nhau với qua các buổi zom này. Rồi mình
xin cảm ơn và chủ đề chính hôm nay á
chúng ta sẽ đi qua cái a à có lẽ là mọi
người cũng đã thấy cái banner hoặc là
cái trang link page mà mình gửi ngày hôm
qua của trên các a group hội nhóm cũng
như là các fanpage hay là Facebook thì
có thông báo là cái chủ đề hôm nay là sẽ
làm về ứng dụng Gravity với Notebook mm
để làm ra một cái website gọi là chuẩn
chỉ à giống như cái trang web của anh
Hải Trình à gọi là Hải Trình org và
người
gọi là chủ cái buổi tối hôm nay chính là
anh Hải Trình ha. Mình chỉ là người hot
thôi nha cả nhà. Mình hoàn toàn luôn là
hôm nay chỉ ngồi lắng nghe và thôi và
lắng nghe trong suốt 3 tiếng mà hôm nay
không dám hói hé. Rồi và xin cảm ơn cả
nhà. Rất mong cả nhà cho anh Trình Hải
Trình một chàng pháo tay ha. Và mình
cũng xin giới thiệu thêm nhé lộn. Anh
Hải Trình hiện nay đang công tác ở Hải
Dương học mà nhưng mà mình không rõ là
còn là công tác cái gì hay không chi
tiết thì chắc lẽ nhờ anh chị em ở đây
khai thác thêm. Rồi Minh xin cảm ơn cả
nhà ạ. Rồi rất vui chào anh Hải Trinh ạ.
Ờ xin chào mọi người. Ờ thật ra thì
như Minh có nói thì hôm nay là mình chỉ
là một cái buổi giao lưu thôi. Mình cũng
chia sẻ những cái mà mình ứng dụng trong
cái công việc của mình thì để
mình chia sẻ cái
desktop. Chia sẻ này chia sẻ desktop
được phải không? Là nó có hết mấy cái
hay là chia sẻ. Đúng rồi. Mình mình
nó có sẽ có chọn
screen là chia sẻ hết luôn á bác. Ờ
>> là mọi người thấy cái cái màn hình
cái slide của mình đâ đúng không?
Ờ nếu mọi người thấy thì cho mình cái số
1 đi. Cho mình cái số 1 mình thấy
rồi.
Thì xin chào mọi người. Thì hôm nay thì
thật ra thì mình với Minh cũng tình cờ
biết nhau thôi. Biết nhau trong các cái
group về AI xong rồi à ờ mình đi học ra
là mình là học trò của Minh đó chứ không
phải là là mình là đi học từ Minh đó.
Rồi mình bắt đầu thực ra thì mình là dân
nghiên cứu mình là một nhà khoa học
ờ mình làm ở Việt Hải Như học hoàn toàn
không có một cái cái nền tảng gì về code
cả nhưng mà mình có một cái trước giờ
mình cũng có thích về IT cũng có tìm
hiểu thôi nhưng mà không có phải là dân
code chuyên nghiệp nên a từ lúc mà mình
không làm được những cái sản phẩm mà
mình mong muốn thì từ khi mà tiếp cận
được với AI và đặc biệt là cái anti
Gravity á từ tháng 1 thì mình mới nảy
sinh ra một cái ý tưởng là mình làm cái
trang web cho bản thân mình mà trước giờ
mình không có làm được. Đó thì cũng chia
sẻ với mọi người cái cách mà mình tiếp
cận như thế nào và sau đó là mình dùng
nó như thế nào. Đó thì à
thì cái hiện tại bây giờ á thì cái a nó
sẽ là cái câu chuyện thôi là từ ý tưởng.
Tại vì thật ra trước đây mình có ý tưởng
nhưng mình không biết làm. Mình à xây
dựng lên cái sản phẩm bây giờ ở hiện tại
á thì tí nữa mọi người nếu mọi người có
thời gian thì mọi người có thể xem qua
cái chức năng rồi những cái mà nó có ở
trong đấy. Vì cái thời gian của mình có
hạn á thì mình chỉ giới thiệu rất là sơ
lược trước cái một cái phần gọi là lý
thuyết trước cho mọi người nắm cái cách
mình làm. Sau đó là mình sẽ ứng dụng
chạy trên antigravity để cho mọi người
thấy cái cái
hiệu quả nó như thế nào.
Thì một cái như Minh giới thiệu thì mình
là làm ở viện Hải Dương học từ năm 2004
thì mình làm nghiên cứu và cách đây 6
năm 5 năm thì mình chuyển sang làm ờ
truyền thông và giáo dục môi trường cho
bảo tàng Hải Dân học là cái nơi mà cũng
thuộc việ hải dân học nhưng mà cái nơi
mà mấy anh chị mà đi Nha Trang chơi á đi
tham quan á xem cá rồi đó thì nó gọi là
bảo tàng hả dân học thì mình chuyển vào
đây với cái mong muốn á là mình mang cái
kiến thức mà mình có
đến với mọi người nhiều hơn, đặc biệt là
các bạn trẻ và học sinh. Thì do đó mình
chuyển sang mình làm cái mảng này. Và
sau 6 năm thì
cái trang web mà mình vừa chạy đây á là
từ ngày 01 tháng
là mình khai trương á gọi là mình khai
trương và mình mất khoảng 3 tháng để
mình làm cái
này. Thì điều đầu tiên trước hết thì
cũng để mọi người biết á là ứng dụng AI
nó cũng không phải là giống như trên
mạng mấy bạn hay nói
ờ cho full đúng không?
Các bạn hay nói trên mạng á là làm một
trang web nó có 1 ngày hay là 30 phút
thì thật ra thì nó cũng không không hẳn.
Mình mất phải 3 tháng thì thật ra thứ
nhất là mình là người không chuyên.
Đó thì sau cái buổi hôm nay nếu mà mọi
người có nhu cầu hoặc là chúng ta có
những cái cần giao lưu thì cũng có thể
liên lạc với mình trên Facebook hoặc là
trên Zalo.
Thì trước mắt thì các bạn có thể thấy là
mình để mình giới thiệu sơ qua cho một
số anh chị mà mà
chưa chưa chưa biết thì đây là cái trang
web của mình. Em cũng ở em
ờ đây là cái trang web của mình thì nó
sẽ có ờ một cái phần là về mặt tin tức
thì sẽ giới thiệu cho các bạn một số cái
thông tin về sinh vật biển và
nó dạng tin tức thôi, dạng news, dạng
cái thông tin và cái mình đang làm ở đây
là muốn đến cho các bạn học sinh á thì
đó là cái phần mà gọi là các khóa học
các khóa học miễn phí về sinh vật biển.
Thì đây là một cái chương trình mà mình
một cái trang web mà mình làm đến bây
giờ thì được các bạn nhỏ và phụ huynh
đánh giá rất là cao.
Thì trong mỗi khóa học đều có hình ảnh,
đều có video minh họa và
các cái nội dung bài học sẽ là các cái
infographic ngắn gọn đầy đủ ý. Và sau
mỗi cái bài học sẽ có một cái bài kiểm
tra ngắn nhỏ. Và cuối cùng á sau khi các
bạn hoàn thành cái khóa học thì các bạn
sẽ có một cái chứng nhận. Thì thì đây là
một cái sản phẩm mà mình nghĩ là nó ờ
mình chưa nói là mình không nói là nó
hoàn chỉnh 100% nhưng mà nó đã đáp ứng
được cái nhu cầu của mình là hiện tại
thì mình có khoảng 300 bạn học sinh ở
trong này. Sau a
2 tháng mình mở thì mình có khoảng 300
bạn học sinh.
thì mình sẽ làm cái việc này như thế
nào? Thì
cái công việc của mình thật ra là solo
nên chỉ có một mình mình làm cộng với
ứng dụng AI và sau 3 tháng thì mình có
cái sản phẩm như vậy. Thì mọi người nãy
mọi người có theo dõi kịp cái nội dung
của trên cái web của mình không ạ?
Ờ mọi người nếu mà thấy được cái đầy đủ
cái nội dung á mọi người cho mình cái
từ từ để mình mở cái số một ra như thế
nào cái chat như thế nào rồi
thì
trước đây mình cũng có thực ra thì đối
với một số anh chị á nếu như mà muốn
mình làm mình muốn làm một cái trang web
về mặt thông tin á thì ngày xưa là mình
cũng có tìm hiểu về WordPress thôi. Nó
là một cái dạng blog. Thì sau khi mình
có làm á thì mình thấy là nó không giải
quyết được những cái mà mình mong muốn
là ví dụ như WordPress thì nó sẽ phải
theo cái các cái plugin detail và mình
không tùy biến được nhiều. Nhưng mà khi
mình phát mình mình tìm hiểu về
antigravity thì thật ra mình không có
kiến thức gì về cái viết app này, viết
web này trên cái cái antiravity hết. thì
mình bắt đầu học bằng cách là nói chuyện
với antiravity thì mình sẽ hỏi nó là
muốn sẽ dựng một cái trang web thì sẽ
như thế nào, sẽ có cái step by step như
thế nào. Và sau đó mình mới khi mà mình
học từ AI mà ai giới thiệu về dữ liệu,
về giao diện rồi về các cái công nghệ
mới thì mình sẽ học từ đó và mình thấy
là nó tùy biến cho mình nhiều hơn. Nên
đó mình chuyển sang mình làm bằng cái
này cái antiravity luôn. Và cái trang
web mình vừa show với mọi người á thì nó
là sản phẩm hoàn toàn của antiravity.
Mình cũng không có biết nhiều về AI nên
khi mình biết về antiravity thì mình chỉ
làm một cái việc đó thôi. Mình cũng
không dùng codex hay là dùng clot
nhiều. Clot thì mình chỉ dùng clot ở
trong cái antiravity thôi. Thì đây là
một cái mình chuyển đổi từ cái kiến thức
mà mình có về WordPress mình chuyển sang
cái này thì được một cái á là ban đầu
mình làm thì những cái mà Superbase hoặc
cái V sale á thì nó miễn phí do đó là
mình tận dụng luôn mình xài nó được miễn
phí. Do đó là để mình vừa nghiên cứu
mình vừa làm. Thì đó là cái mình cái
hiện tại bây giờ thì hiện tại thì cái
những cái nguồn này nó đang miễn phí.
Thì để giới thiệu với mọi người á có một
số anh chị á nếu mà mình xài AI và đặc
biệt là cái
gồm đây mọi người nói AI agent á thì nó
sẽ khác với cái AI bình thường. Trước
đây mình cũng chỉ là chat thôi và trước
đây nếu muốn làm một cái WordPress đó,
một cái trang đó thì mình phải thuê khá
là đắc. Thì khi mình biết antiravity
mình nói chuyện với nó thì sau khoảng 1
ngày là nó đã cho mình cái khung rồi là
cái khung là là mình sẽ có cái gì, mình
sẽ làm được cái gì và mình cảm thấy là
ok nó có thể triển khai được thì và nó
bổ sung cho cái phần mình mong muốn á là
mà workpress mình không làm được thì bên
này nó làm rất là tốt.
Thì ở đây á cái quan trọng nhất của mình
muốn nói với mọi người ở đây á thì thật
ra thì ai nó không phải là là
ừ thần thánh gì cả. Thực ra nó cũng chỉ
là cái thực thi thôi. Còn quan trọng là
ở chỗ cái của mình á thì nên trước khi
mà mọi người bắt tay có thể bắt tay vào
làm một cái dự án cá nhân của mọi người
á thì mọi người có thể sử dụng cái
ý tưởng của mình trước và sau đó ai sẽ
thực thi thì trong đó là vì mình làm về
content, mình làm về nội dung khóa học.
Nên mình sử dụng thêm là notebook để
mình à
xây dựng các cái bài học mà nó tốt nhất.
Thì đối với con người thì trước tiên á
thì mình cũng muốn là các bạn là các bạn
phải hình dung ra được là các anh các
chị phải hình dung ra được là mình phải
có ý tưởng của mình là cái gì. Xong rồi
mình nghĩ là cái phần của mình muốn á là
nó sẽ có cái gì và gồm cấu trúc như thế
nào, chức năng ra sao, xong rồi màu sắc
mình mong muốn là cái gì thì lúc đó mình
đưa cái tất cả cái này giao cho AI nó
thực thi. Thì
trước đây thì AI kiểu mình chat thôi. Ví
dụ như các anh chị mà dùng chat CBT như
ngày xưa cách đây vài năm thì chúng ta
chỉ có là chat thôi, trả lời câu hỏi
thôi. Thì bây giờ thì AI nó sẽ thực thi
luôn. Đó thì có nghĩa là mình ở đây mình
sau khi mình brainstorm ý tưởng xong á
thì mình sẽ sẽ giao cái công việc mà
thiết kế cái phần cứng phần mềm cho cho
ai nó làm. Đó thì ở đây mình cái
antiravity thì nếu như một số anh chị
nào mà trong nhóm mình á thì chắc cũng
nghe cũng biết nhiều rồi. Thì hiện tại
bây giờ là antiravity 2.0 là Minh đang
làm rất là tốt. Nhưng bản thân mình thì
mình vẫn đang sử dụng cái bản Antia
Gravity ID thì cái bản cái bảng để mình
trò chuyện và mình setup thôi. Thì cái
antiravity nó sẽ cho mình truy cập vào
file trên máy rồi nó viết code, nó thiết
kế rồi nó sẽ gọi những cái AI khác ra để
làm việc cùng để miễn sao mà nó thành nó
nó cho mình một cái kết quả mà mình mong
muốn. Và hay ở cái chỗ là nó giao tiếp
100% bằng tiếng Việt. Thì từ lúc mình
làm việc với nó tới giờ thì chỉ có nói
tiếng Việt bình thường thôi, cũng không
có phải là ngôn ngữ code hay gì cả. Thật
ra mình nói chuyện với nó rất là bình
thường là tôi muốn cái này, tôi muốn làm
cái việc này, việc này nó có cái gì, cần
cái gì, cái gì, cái gì thì mình cũng
trao đổi giống như là một trao đổi với
một cái cái cái cái con người bình
thường thì tí nữa mọi người có thể thấy
một số các cái độ hội thoại của mình với
antiravity.
Thì mình sẽ giao cho antiravity cái gì?
Thứ nhất là mình giao cho nó thiết kế,
mình giao cho nó lập trình, mình giao
cho nó cái việc lưu trữ và xuất bản.
Đó thì vai trò của mình ở đây làm gì?
Vai trò của mình ở đây là mình duyệt
những cái
mà nó làm mình đồng ý hay không rồi mình
mới cho nó làm. Đó thì cái nguyên tắc
của mình khi mình làm với nó là mình chỉ
yêu cầu là
tôi không có cần bạn mô tả tôi cách làm
như thế nào mà tôi chỉ cần là bạn mô tả
tôi kết quả thôi. Tôi muốn như vậy và
kết quả các bạn đưa ra là cái gì. Và có
một cái mình có một cái yêu cầu với anti
Gravity đó là tất cả mọi cái thông tin
mà trước khi nó bắt đầu làm thì mình
phải là cái người duyệt. Tại vì có những
cái lần đầu tiên mình làm á mình hỏi cái
nó làm luôn có nghĩa là nó chạy tút luôn
nó chạy luôn và nó không cần biết là
đúng sai thì nó làm luôn thì sau đó mình
mới bắt nó là phải để cho tu duyệt cái
đã thì mới được làm. Và kết quả mình
thấy là cái AI nó giỏi nhất là khi mà
các bạn biết là mình muốn cái gì.
Ví dụ như trang web của mình, mình cần
có năm cái bản tin ở trên cái trang
chính chẳng hạn thì mình phải biết là
mình sắp xếp nó như thế nào, mình phải
mô tả được cho
nó và mình phải mình phải hiểu là mình
muốn cái gì thì ai nó mới làm đúng theo
cái ý của mình chứ mình không nói là
chung chung là viết cho tôi đoạn code
này hay là như thế nào đó mà mình sẽ có
những cái
cái nào mình thiệt sự mình muốn mình
mình phải hiểu mình muốn á thì mình mới
trao đổi với với với AI để cho nó làm
cái việc đó cho mình. Đó thì ở trong cái
antiravity
thì cái này là cái mình có thể là ừ giới
thiệu để cho các bạn các anh chị là
trước khi mình bắt tay vô làm á thì mình
sẽ hình dung ra được là một cái dự án sẽ
cần cái gì. Thì hiện tại ở trong
antiravity của mình á thì mình sẽ có một
cái gọi là cái bộ nhớ, một cái cái
folder là bộ nhớ, một cái folder về quy
tắc ứng xử có nghĩa là cái rule và cái
skill là các cái công cụ để làm việc.
Thì để anh chị hình dung thì ba cái này
nó sẽ làm thành một cái trợ lý mà cho
cho mình. Thì ví dụ như memory á của của
cái trang web của Hải trình á thì nó sẽ
là tổng hợp hết tất tật những cái mà bắt
đầu từ dự án cho tới hiện tại bây giờ là
có cái gì đó thì nó sẽ lưu vào trong cái
memory này. Thì cái memory cái phiên đầu
tiên làm việc mà chính thức của mình á
với Anti Gravity đã xây dựng cái trang
web này á là bắt đầu từ ngày 8 tháng
còn cái giai đoạn từ tháng 1 tới tháng 2
là cái giai đoạn mình tìm hiểu anti
Gravity là gì và anti gravity làm được
gì thì sau đó là mình bắt tay vào chính
thức mà gọi là tí nữa mình sẽ cho các
bạn xem các anh chị xem cái cái cái file
memory này nó gồm cái gì ở trong đấy.
Thì cái memory nó một cái rất là quan
trọng mà giống như hôm hôm trước nếu anh
chị nào có nghe cái buổi của Khoa á về
bộ nhớ thứ hai á thì cái dạng memory này
của mình thì nó không không như Khoa
nhưng mà nó sẽ nằm ở trong cái dự án này
thôi. Nó chỉ nằm trong dự án này và tất
tập những thay đổi những cái cập nhật
mới nó đều nằm trong này để cho cái cái
AI của mình á nó nhớ và nó biết được là
khi mình kêu nó lên làm thì nó sẽ làm
cái gì. Tiếp theo
thì cái ru đó cái ru thì nó sẽ có nhiều
nhiều kiểu à trong cái của mình thì mình
sẽ có yêu cầu về cái ru về ngôn ngữ rồi
mình sẽ có những cái quy tắc về thiết kế
như thế nào và cái này cái cái các anh
chị đang xem trên màn hình á nó là cái
kết quả của cái quá trình mà nó ai nó tự
học. Có nghĩa là mình có một cái skill,
mình có một cái yêu cầu là sau cái mỗi
cái session á là nó phải lưu lại những
cái thay đổi, những cái nào mà mình nói
là không được làm cái đấy phải làm bằng
cách này thì nó sẽ lưu vào để nó làm.
Thì mình cũng sẽ cho tí nữa các bạn cũng
sẽ được xem những cái cái cái mẫu này.
Thì trong thư mục của một cái A, một cái
trợ lý AI á thì thường là sẽ có bốn cái
loại như vậy. Bốn cái là một cái là cái
bộ nhớ nè, cái cái rule để nó làm việc
theo ý của mình. Thì các bạn phải biết
là mình muốn các anh chị phải biết là
mình muốn cái gì. Có nghĩa là ờ con ai
của mình á thì mình sẽ xét cho nó là
không được xưng hô mày tao nè, không
được xưng hô ông tui nè mà chỉ gọi là
chú và em chú trình thấy không? Chú chú
Trình và xưng em chẳng hạn. Thì thì sau
này tất cả các cái trả lời của nó đều
follow theo cái ru đấy. Và cái skill là
những cái cái những cái gọi là cái kỹ
năng mà mình nạp vào để cho cái AI này
nó hỗ trợ mình. Thì tí nữa cũng sẽ có
những một số các cái demo, các skill cho
mọi người xem.
Thì cái memory thì như mình nói nó là
trái tim của dự án rồi. Nó lưu hết tập
những cái thông tin vào đấy. Mình bắt nó
phải lưu vào đấy. Thì tí nữa là nó lưu
như thế nào thì mọi người cũng sẽ được
được xem. Ờ cái ru thì giúp cái AI nó
làm việc theo cái phong cách của bạn
đúng không? Mình thấy có một số bạn ở
trên các cái group á thì cho nó xưng hô
mày tao xả láng. Có nghĩa là nó thoải
mái, có nghĩa là cho nó. Nhưng mình thì
không, mình thì bắt nó phải làm là
khi mà nói chuyện với tôi là phải là
xưng hô trú trình. Bắt buộc là không có
ông tôi gì hết á, không có mày tao gì
cả. và bắt nó phải có cái này là cái anh
chị có thể là xét cho cái AI của mình để
nó làm việc theo cái mong muốn của mình
là như thế nào. Đó ví dụ như trước khi
nó trả lời thì nó phải phản biện, nó
phải suy nghĩ và nó phải tìm kiếm những
cái cơ sở lập luận như thế nào đó để nó
làm việc với mình chứ nó không phải là
ào phát là xong. Thì hồi trước á khi mà
mới làm á thì cái clot nó chuyện rất
đàng hoàng. Còn con Chemini á nói chuyện
rất ba lơm. Nó nói chuyện rất là nó
giống như con RCK á. Mày tao rồi ông tui
có nghĩa là cháu sẽ xử cái cái này cho
chú rồi có nghĩa là nó nói chuyện rất là
buồn cười nhưng mình lại mình lại không
thích. Thật ra mình cũng cũng
cà lỡn thiệt nhưng mà mình không thích
trong cái lúc làm việc nó cợt nhã với
mình nhiều quá nên mình xét cho nó cái
ru luôn. Thì sau đó thì mọi cái luồng
chat của mình nó đều follow cái nguyên
tắc làm việc của mình.
Còn cái skill là những cái những cái
công cụ, những cái kỹ năng mà mình đưa
vào. Ví dụ như ờ muốn thiết kế thì mình
phải có một cái mình không phải là dân
thiết kế về màu sắc nhiều không biết về
code nên do đó mình phải có một cái
skill để cho nó thiết kế là ví dụ như là
ờ màu sắc sẽ như thế nào, tương phản ra
sao, thì đối với giáo dục thì nó sẽ màu
gì và đối với đại dương nó sẽ có những
cái bảng màu như thế nào và mình có một
cái những cái skill về viết bài đó thì
tí nữa mình cũng sẽ share cho mọi người
cái bộ skill này có một cái skill của
cái thầy của thầy Tùng À thầy có một cái
skill về viết bài chuyên nghiệp thì có
nghĩa là họ sẽ đã viết cái skill đó và
họ cái skill đó sẽ cho mình cái ngôn ngữ
viết nó không phải là ngôn ngữ của AI và
tránh luôn những cái lỗi mà AI nó hay nó
hay mắt phải. Ví dụ như viết tiếng Việt
thì nó viết hoa theo kiểu của tiếng Anh
đó. Rồi nó sẽ dùng dấu slash à dấu những
cái dấu nối thay cho dấu hai chấm. nó sẽ
có những cái lỗi như vậy thì cái skill
đó nó khắc phục luôn cho mình và nó sẽ
sửa luôn cái ngữ pháp những cái câu văn
như thế nào cho nó hợp lý đó và những
cái skill mà liên quan tới viết bài thì
tí nữa mình cũng sẽ thị phạm cho mọi
người xem một chút.
Đó thì sau khi mình có các skill rồi thì
mình sẽ đến một cái gọi là workflow.
Workflow nó là một chuỗi các cái skill
liên kết với nhau. Ví dụ như mình có một
cái skill về viết bài viết khóa học. một
cái skill về public cái khóa học thì để
mà mình không phải kêu gọi nhiều cái kỹ
năng một lần thì mình làm thành một cái
workflow. Thì cái workflow có nghĩa là
nó sẽ kêu cái skill viết bài ra. Nó viết
bài xong rồi nó sẽ kêu cái skill publish
lên trang web thì nó sẽ thành một cái
workflow. Thì mọi người cứ nô na hình
dung là nó sẽ gồm nhiều cái kỹ năng và
nó là ra một cái công việc cuối cùng.
Và đó là cái phần mà mình dùng để cho nó
viết phần cứng đó. Ai nó viết phần cứng.
Và cái phần mà mình về mặt nội dung thì
notebook thì chắc mọi người cũng biết
nhiều đúng không?
Ờ notbook của Google thì nó là một trong
những cái AI mà mình sử dụng hàng ngày
luôn cho công việc nghiên cứu nè, cho
công việc học tập và cho cái các cái
xuất bản, các cái ấn phẩm về infographic
rồi slide. Thì cái slide mọi người đang
xem ở đây cũng là một cái sản phẩm của
Notebook LM. Đó thì là cũng một sản phẩm
mà mọi người đang xem ở đây. Thì cái lợi
thế của Nob thì mình dùng ở đây là vì nó
đọc đúng tài liệu mà mình chọn xong rồi
nó chỉ trả lời trong phạm vi tài liệu
thôi và trích dẫn nguồn rất là tốt. Do
đó là mình sử dụng notebook để mình làm
cái nguồn cơ sở về mặt
thông tin khóa học. Một bài học đó mình
cần những cái gì, mình làm như thế nào
thì mình sẽ dùng mặt nốb OM. Nhưng mà
mình tích hợp cái notebook này vào trong
antiravity để nó tạo nên những cái
skill, những cái workflow mà mình không
phải làm nữa. Mình chỉ mình chỉ ra lệnh
thôi thì nó sẽ tự thực thi. Đó thì tí
nữa mọi người cũng sẽ sẽ xem.
Thì hiện tại tới bây giờ là mình đang có
khoảng 72 cái cái cái chuyên đề 72 cái
bài học mà mình sử dụng từ cho cái cái
cái trang web của mình. Thì hiện tại
đang có public thì khoảng 10 bài thì còn
lại những cái bài kia là nó nằm trong
cái kế hoạch của lâu dài.
Thì cái notebook OM nó sẽ là cái bộ não
tri thức của mình hiện tại và antiravity
nó sẽ là cái bàn tay mà nó sẽ thực thi
cho mình. Đó thì cái quy trình của mình
để mình làm với notebook thì nó cũng sẽ
AI nó cũng antiravity nó cũng sẽ làm nó
mình bắt nó làm. Thứ nhất là nó sẽ kiểm
tra trên notebook là có cái sinh vật mà
mình yêu cầu chưa hoặc là cái chủ đề
mình đang làm có chưa và mình bắt buộc
là nó phải có các cái nguồn ít nhất là
10 nguồn đó và sau đó là chích xất các
cái thông tin nó ra thành các cái bài
giảng thành cái khóa học và đóng gói lại
thành những cái bài học và sau đó đưa về
cho antiravity để antiravity tiếp tục
cái công việc là
chắc lọc
viết lại đó viết lại chắc lọc viết lại
và phân bổ theo vô cái khóa học của mình
thì một cái workflow mà mình đang hiện
tại là cái workflow cuối cùng của mình
đang dùng ở đây thì mình sẽ tổng hợp hết
tất tật những cái skill nó vào trong một
cái workflow. Thứ nhất là mình sẽ thiết
kế cái bài giảng như thế nào. Rồi xong
rồi sẽ có cái nghiên cứu nghiên cứu về
thông tin tạo các cái luồng nghiên cứu
về thông tin rồi mình sẽ đưa về lại cho
antiravity đó để nó viết lại để nó đưa
cái giọng điệu cái văn phong của mình á
cái văn phong của của mình vào trong cái
cái bài viết và sau đó là mình sẽ kiểm
soát cái lỗi và
trong cái quá trình đó thì nó sẽ làm
luôn cho mình là mỗi một cái bài đó là
infographic là nó sẽ tự tạo cho mình
luôn và video và cái slide bài giảng thì
đây là một cái quy trình mà mình dùng
anti gravity để mình viết cho nó để nó
kêu notebook ra làm hết tất tật mọi thứ
kể cả là tạo quiz tạo flash card ở trong
cái bài học của mình và sau đó cuối cùng
á là mình chỉ là cái người mà đọc cái
sản phẩm cuối cùng mình kiểm duyệt và
mình xuất bản thì cái việc xuất bản cũng
là do antiravity làm nó sẽ tự phân ra
thành theo hệ thống theo cái dạng code
lập trình khác nhau để nó đưa lên trên
hệ thống một cách là nhanh nhất mà nó
mình không phải làm. Hồi xưa mình làm
Wordr thì mình phải copy mình đưa nội
dung vào từng cái block này block kia
rồi mình thiết kế nó hình ảnh nó ở chỗ
này chỗ kia như thế nào thì bây giờ là
cái antiravity nó sẽ làm cho mình luôn.
Do đó là mình tiết kiệm được rất là
nhiều thời gian trong cái việc mà xuất
bản các cái ống phẩm thì đó là cái quy
trình mà hiện tại mình đang làm cho với
antiravity. và notebook và mình cũng có
thêm một cái quy trình nhỏ để viết cái
các cái bài blog
thì
nó cũng sẽ đi tìm những cái chủ đề đang
hot nó tìm những cái chủ đề ví dụ mình
đưa ra một con cái thông tin là mình đưa
ra một cái đối tượng là con cá nhám vo
chẳng hạn thì nó anti gravity nó sẽ đi
tìm là trên mạng đang nói gì về con cá
nhám voi có cái gì hot như thế nào và nó
sẽ research nó research vấn đề đó xong
rồi nó sẽ viết lại cho mình và chuẩn
theo cái cái cái sale hiện tại bây giờ
và sau đó là chia sẻ cái bài đó ra thành
các cái bài nhỏ để mình dùng trên trên
a trên Facebook thì nó cũng là một cái
quy trình để mình mình cũng đã có một
cái quy trình như vậy để mình tiết kiệm
được thời gian cho mình. Thì đó là cái
bước cuối cùng là cái bước xuất bản nó
lên trên cái trang web thôi. Thì
kết quả là sau 3 tháng thì mình có một
cái trang web hoàn chỉnh và 3300 học
viên với mấy a hơn 10.000 hơn 10.000
ngàn cái lượt truy cập trong trong 2
tháng vừa rồi thì mình thấy là nếu như
mà trước đây không có cái AI á thì mình
chỉ có ý tưởng thôi, mình không thực
hiện được. Nên là mình
đối với mình thì ai nó có một cái hỗ trợ
cho mình rất là nhiều đó để thực hiện
cái công việc này.
Thì trước khi mà mình muốn là mọi người
sau cái buổi ngày hôm nay mà mọi người
muốn làm ờ một cái sản phẩm hoặc một cái
dự án cá nhân của mình mà liên quan tới
thì mình nên có những cái câu hỏi
như mà mà mình đã làm. Mình đã hỏi trước
đây á khi mình làm á là mình sẽ làm cho
ai và họ người ta nhận được cái gì và
cái cái điểm độc đáo của mình là cái gì
và tính năng mà mình vượt trội hơn những
cái cái cái sản phẩm khác là chỗ nào.
Thì nếu mà mọi người trả lời được những
câu hỏi này và mọi người trao đổi với
với Antigravity á thì sẽ có những cái
góc nhìn mới hay để mình bắt tay vô cái
cái cái dự án của mình. Thì đối với cái
dự án của hình.org á thì mình có móc
khoảng đúng là khoảng a
một hơn 1 tháng đầu tiên là tìm hiểu và
khoảng a 5 tuần để mình viết mình ngồi
với nó. Thật ra thì ngồi tới mức mà vợ
muốn bắt ôm cái laptop đi ra ngoài luôn
á.
Đó thì ừ triển khai tới bây giờ
và hiện tại á mình dùng tại vì sao? Là
vì hầu như là miễn phí. Ngoại trừ cái
đầu tiên thì anti gravity mình cũng xài
miễn phí nhưng mà khi mình tới lúc mình
trả phí thì mình nhu cầu cao rồi mình
phải trả phí. Còn lại những cái cơ sở
khác như Superpay Vale và Notebook thì
nó đều mình giai đoạn mà mình làm á cho
tới lúc khai chương á nó đều là miễn
phí. Thì khi mà lượng người dùng bắt đầu
tăng thì buộc là mình phải mua cái gói
của Superb để cho đảm bảo là mọi người
đăng ký cái học viên nó được tốt nhất.
Thì đây là cái mà
phần lý thuyết mà mình sẽ mình giới
thiệu với mọi người. Thì một cái quan
trọng mà thực ra mình cũng hay nói với
cả anh em ở trong cơ quan hay chia sẻ
với nhau thì ai nó không thay thế được ờ
ý tưởng của mình. nó chỉ giúp mình là
thực hiện hóa cái ý tưởng nó nhanh hơn
thôi. Thì cũng hy vọng là sau cái buổi
ngày hôm nay nếu như một số anh chị em
mà mới tiếp cận thì có thể tìm hiểu thêm
và thử thử dùng đó thử dùng cái a những
cái công cụ này. Thì cái phần mà mình
chia sẻ về phần lý thuyết thì nó sẽ như
thế này. Thì trước khi mà mình thị phạm
bằng AI để cho mọi người xem thì mọi
người có thể mình có thể trao đổi một
chút. Đó, mình có thể trao đổi một chút.
Ờ mình có thể mọi người có thể trao đổi
thêm một chút về cái cái cái cách mình
sử dụng như thế nào. Mọi người có thắc
mắc gì hoặc là mọi người có cần cái
giới thiệu thêm về kỹ về một cái phần
nào đó không thì mình sẽ a trao đổi.
Alo
>> alo alo à
>> tạm thời có anh chị em nào có thắc mắc
mình có comment là cứ nói để anh Hải
Trình chia sẻ thêm rồi sau đó mình đi
thêm luôn cả nhà
hay là cái mình cứ đi tiếp chương trình
để khúc sau mình chia mình mình mình
mình kill nay sau luôn bác Trình ơi. Rồi
thì ở đây mình
thựt ra thì nếu mà đi vô cái này á thì
mọi người sẽ thấy là nó sẽ hơi
nó sẽ hơi lùng bùng. Để mình mình sẽ
giới thiệu sơ qua về cái cấu trúc của
cái mình
mình giới thiệu với mọi người á. Thì mọi
người vẫn đang thấy cái
mọi người vẫn đang thấy cái cái màn hình
của mình đúng không? Cái màn hình
antiravity đúng không?
Ừ thì ở đây á, ở đây mình sẽ có
antiravity nó là một cái
AI của Google thì mọi người có thể dùng
bằng account Google thì miễn phí chúng
ta cũng dùng được. Ờ trả phí thì chúng
ta dùng được nhiều hơn và trả phí ultra
thì chúng ta dùng nó thoải mái hơn một
chút. Thì ở trong nãy mình có nói thì
đầu tiên thì chúng ta sẽ có một cái hệ
agent. một cái hệ là cái mà trợ lý AI
của mình á thì nó sẽ bao gồm rất là
nhiều những cái nó giống như là một cái
bộ não của mình ở trong đấy thì nó sẽ
bao gồm có cái memory thấy chưa? Mình sẽ
có một cái memory ở đây. Thì cái memory
của mình á thì để cho mọi người dễ hình
dung là trong cái memory của dự án của
của hải trình á thì sẽ có rất là sẽ bao
nó sẽ bao quát hết tất tật những cái gì
mà mình làm đó. về công nghệ, về những
tất cả mọi thứ. Thực ra thì ờ Hương nói
thì có vẻ phức tạp nhưng mà đúng là đầu
tiên là cũng phức tạp thiệt đối với mình
nhưng mà khi mình sử dụng với nó thì
mình cảm thấy là à nó không không như
mình nghĩ, không phức tạp quá như mình
nghĩ. Thì ở đây mình có cấu trúc các cái
thư mục. Có nghĩa là cái cái memory này
á là nó giống như là cái bộ não của cái
dự án này luôn. có nghĩa là cái phần app
của mình nó nằm ở đâu, gồm những trang
nào, gồm những cái gì thì nó đều nằm ở
trong này hết. Đó.
Ờ thì ở đây sẽ có rất là nhiều cái
thông tin thì hầu như là dự án của mình
nó nằm trên này hết. Thì sau này tất cả
những cái mà ai mà những cái mình hỏi
tiếp theo á trong cái quá trình mình hỏi
mình cứ làm tiếp á thì nó sẽ cái việc
của nó là nó sẽ lôi cái memory ra nó đọc
đó. nó đọc để mình biết là cái ngày đó
nó làm được cái gì đó và cái cấu trúc
của mình như thế nào. Thì do đó là hiện
tại nha mọi người cứ mình thấy nhiều
nhiều cái cái bài post trên Facebook á
trên các group lại cứ chửi ai ngu hoặc
là nó quên nhưng mà mình lại không thấy
cái việc đấy.
á
em à Trung đang hỏi cái attention thì em
tí em lên em search cái attention là
ờ
attention
gì nhỉ? Office viewer nha Trung ơi.
Thì cái Office Viewer nó sẽ cho chúng ta
xem nó giống như trên Word á thì chúng
ta dễ dễ theo dõi hơn. Thì cái memory
thứ nhất là cái memory, cái thứ hai là
cái ru. Thực ra cái ru cái ru là cái mà
mình nghĩ nó rất là quan trọng và cái ru
này của mình có khá là nhiều ru đó. Cái
ru thứ nhất đó là ru về ngôn ngữ. Ngôn
ngữ nãy mình có show cho mọi người xem
rồi thì đó là cái ru về ngôn ngữ và cái
ru về
ờ thảo luận. Có nghĩa là luôn luôn phải
thảo luận với mình chứ không được làm
luôn. Thì đây là một cái ru đó là một
cái ru thứ hai. Và một cái ru thứ ba đó
là cái ru về backup. Có nghĩa là mình
cho nó một cái ru là trước khi làm cái
gì nó phải backup hết. Nó phải lưu lại
thành ở trong cái folder backup để mình
tránh cái trường hợp là buồn buồn nó xóa
mất đi hoặc là nó mất cái bị lỗi thì
mình luôn luôn có cái ru về backup. thì
mọi người cũng nên có một cái ru về như
vậy. Thì đó là về ru. Còn về cái memory
mình có một cái memory mình muốn giới
thiệu với mọi người nữa đó là về button.
Thì cái này á cái memory này nó sẽ ép AI
là
FAI nó sẽ thực hiện theo cái
mà mình khi nó trao đổi với mình á mà
sai á.
nó làm sai và mình bắt nó là không được
làm như vậy thì nó sẽ lưu vào trong cái
memory này sau mỗi cái buổi nói chuyện.
Ví dụ như mình thấy có một cái lỗi về từ
đồng nghĩa khi viết ai khi khi viết bài
học thì mình bắt nó là không được làm
như vậy.
Hoặc là có những cái
lỗi mà nó về ờ cấu trúc bên trong mình
không muốn nó xảy ra cái lỗi đó nữa thì
mình cho nó lưu vào trong cái memory
này. Đó.
Ờ Tài có hỏi là
memory này á, cái memory này là AI nó tự
tự làm nha Tài. Cái memory này là AI nó
sẽ tự cập nhật sau mỗi mỗi phiên làm
việc nó sẽ tự cập nhật những cái memory
này lên đây. Thì và cái này là cái room
và cái skill là cái mà sống còn cái
skill đối với mình ở đây thì hiện tại
bây giờ đang cũng khá là nhiều các cái
skill trong này. có những skill thật ra
là dùng rất là ít thì ờ không không dùng
nhiều, chủ yếu là mình sẽ dùng những cái
skill về viết khóa học. Thì ví dụ như
một cái skill viết khóa học thì nó sẽ
bao gồm những cái
skill có nghĩa là cái kỹ năng mà khi mà
các bạn chỉ cần bấm gọi nó ra thôi nó sẽ
làm. Thì ở đây là một cái skill viết
khóa học đó. Thì mình chỉ cần ờ khi nào
dùng cái skill này thì mình chỉ cần là
gọi tên thôi. Đó, viết bài viết cho chú
khóa học về cái gì đó thì nó sẽ làm cho
cho mình. Thì để mình thị phạm cho các
bạn xem thử là nó làm được cái gì.
Ví dụ như bây giờ mình sẽ
mình sẽ viết khóa học ha. Viết viết khóa
học đó. Thì có nghĩa là cái skill mà
mình khi mình bấm slap ở trên cái đoạn
chat mình kêu nó ra. Đó ví dụ như mình
nói về cái mập cá mập trắng đi.
Rồi để mình dụng cái flash đi cho nó
nhanh.
Thì có nghĩa là cái AI nó sẽ đọc cái
skill của mình và sau đó nó sẽ làm theo
nó sẽ đi làm theo những cái mình trong
này mình đưa ra. Ví dụ như trong này cấu
trúc của một cái bài học của mình là bao
gồm cái gì, tiêu đề như thế nào, câu hút
ở đâu đó. Rồi trong đó sẽ có những cái
bút pháp gì? Có nghĩa là mình cái skill
này là mình làm dựa trên
một dựa trên cái khoảng thời gian mà sau
khi mình làm xong á thì mình mới đút kết
lại mình rút ra thì cách viết rồi có
nghĩa là có một cái skill mà của Minh
chia sẻ và mình dùng cái nó cái skill
của Minh chia sẻ đó là cái skill để viết
skill thì mình dùng cái đó để mình viết
ra những cái skill này thì các bạn thấy
là
thì các bạn thấy là đây là sau khi mình
làm mình mình kêu nó ra thì nó làm cho
mình một cái
bài viết cái mập trắng chú tể tại dương
hay là kẻ về hiểu lầm thì có nghĩa là
mục tiêu của cái bài học này thì nó sẽ
có những cái mục tiêu này mình đưa ra
những cái này nó nằm ở trong cái skill
rồi đó nó sẽ làm thôi và mình hiện tại
cái này là nó không dùng qua notebook
cái này nó tự viết cái này là ai nó tự
viết là mình chưa chưa có kiểm chứng
mình chưa kiểm chứng
Ờ tí nữa nha, tí nữa mình sẽ chia sẻ lại
cái skill này của anh Minh. À mình sẽ có
mình đã chuẩn bị cho các bạn có một cái
món quà cho các bạn. Đó là những cái
skill mà cơ bản mà mình dùng. Đầu tiên á
mình sẽ chia sẻ cái gói skill này với
các bạn. Các bạn cứ ngồi cái cuối thì
các bạn nhận cái gói skill này. Đó thì
các bạn thấy rồi thấy không? Nó sẽ viết
cho mình một cái bài rất là nhanh theo
cái yêu cầu của mình. Đây là cái skill
cái bên cái ở giữa là cái skill nha các
bạn. Và cái bên phải là cái kết quả. Các
bạn thấy không? Nó trả về kết quả cho
mình. Giống như cái mình yêu cầu ở skill
là skill này mình gồm cái gì thì nó sẽ
viết cho mình như thế theo cấu trúc như
vậy. Thì đây là cái mà nó sẽ tự viết nó
chưa qua cái cái notebook.
Thì đây là cái skill về viết bài. Thì
sau khi viết bài rồi thì mình sẽ có cái
gọi là public cái bài này lên trên trang
web thì sẽ có một cái skill là
cost public cái skill số 4 á các bạn.
Thì cái cost này nó sẽ public cho mình.
Đó thì đây là một cái gọi là mình làm
ứng dụng cái antiraity nó cơ bản nhất
cho cái nội dung của mình. Thì sau đó
mình mới phát hiện ra là mình có thể ứng
dụng cái notebook vào trong cái
antiravity luôn. Thì trước đây á thì
mình dùng qua MCB. MCB là một cái cổng
kết nối của các AI với nhau nhưng mà nó
có một cái dở là nó sẽ tốn token rất là
nhiều khi nó đọc một cái vấn đề đầu tiên
thì sau đó mình mới chuyển sang dùng cái
gọi là mình không biết từ chuyên môn nó
là cái gì đâu nhưng mà nó gọi là C CLI á
một cũng một cái dạng cổng kết nối nhưng
mà nó nhanh hơn.
Thì để mà tích hợp cái này vô trong
antiravity thì cách đơn giản nhất là các
bạn nói với antiravity cài cho tôi cái
CLI
CLI à notebook
thì nó sẽ antiravity sẽ tự cài cái Note
vào trong cái hệ thống của
anti Gravity và sau đó mình chỉ cần bắt
tắt nó làm thôi. Thì mình đây mình sẽ
thị phạm cho các bạn xem một cái skill
về một cái cái cái viết bài về cái sử
dụng cái notebook của em. Thì ở đây nó
sẽ làm
thì mình sẽ làm cho các bạn một cái cái
mà cái workflow lớn nhất á mà mình làm à
cái cái mà nãy mình trình bày ở trên cái
cái
cái slide á thì cũng cái mập trắng ha.
Bây giờ mình sẽ làm một cái cost full
build về cái mập trắng.
về chủ đề là con cá mập trắng đi
thì cái code full build này nó nằm nó có
nó là một cái workflow là mình đã tổng
hợp cái workflow này nó thành tất cả
những cái bước mà gọi notebook ra làm
như thế nào như thế nào thì mình đã tạo
thành cái workflow này thì cái workflow
này nó rất là dài. Nếu mình nói về mặt
code á thì nó rất là dài. Nó có rất là
nhiều pha đó có nó sẽ đi làm như thế nào
để mọi người có thể xem. Thì
mọi người có thể xem ở đây kết quả là nó
sẽ làm cái gì.
Đó là mọi người thấy là nó đi search
trong cái cơ sở dữ liệu của mình á. Cái
khóa học của mình đúng là nó sẽ hơi phức
tạp. Ban đầu nó sẽ hơi phức tạp một chút
nhưng mà khi mình
nắm được á là nó chỉ tự làm thôi các
bạn. Nó chỉ tự làm thôi. Mình không có
phải đụng tay vào. Thì mình sẽ để cho
các bạn xem là nó đang gọi cái trên này
đang chạy nè là anti gravity nó chạy nền
thôi. Nó sẽ gọi ra một cái khóa học.
Ờ à để trong lúc nó chạy thì mình trả
lời một số thắc mắc ở đây ha. Thì memory
á memory ở đây là
anh tạo có nghĩa là anh bắt nó tạo một
cái file memory lưu hết những cái mà nó
làm đó. lưu hết những cái nó làm xong
rồi nó sẽ lưu vào đấy một cái file một
cái file là memory.md thì để sau này
mình cứ mỗi ngày mình làm á mỗi ngày
mình mở máy mình lên mình làm mình hỏi
làm cái gì thì nó sẽ có cơ sở nó lôi ra
và nó sẽ trả lời cho mình. Đó còn cái
chỗ mà skill
skill thì mọi người cũng sẽ thấy là nó
sẽ
cái cái này tí nữa mình chia sẻ nha. Và
cái workflow này á là thực ra là mình
nói anti viết cho mình cái workflow này
dựa trên cái mình đang có.
Thì bây giờ nó như thế này. Bây giờ mọi
người hình dung nó như thế này. Cái
memory là bộ nhớ rồi, mình không cần
phải đụng tới. Có nghĩa là memory đó
mình có một cái skill để mình gọi nó bắt
nó phải tí nữa mình xong hết mình sẽ lưu
lại cho các bạn xem thì nó sẽ như thế
nào. Thì
cái ru là cái mà mình phải có đầu tiên.
Các bạn phải lưu ý là cái ru là các bạn
phải nói đầu tiên để nó làm việc theo
đúng cái ru của mình ha. Thì
xong cái ru rồi tới cái skill và có
skill rồi các bạn mới làm workflow. Có
nghĩa là cái workflow của anh ở đây là
anh sẽ luôi đây nè các bạn. Nhìn đây ha.
Mình sẽ mở cái a
cái workflow này đầu tiên nè, đầu tiên
là nó phải tìm, nó phải tạo nè. Thứ nhất
là nó phải tạo nó dùng cái gì?
Nó dùng cái gì để tạo? Nó dùng cái gì để
research? Thì ở đây là
để mình xem nó cái cái phần mà
giờ mình tiếu nha.
Bây giờ nói sao cho các bạn dễ hiểu ha.
Ừm.
Thôi bây giờ như thế này để các bạn dễ
hiểu nè là mình sẽ có cái skill về cost
outline ha. Mình sẽ có cái skill về viết
bài và mình có một cái skill về publish,
mình sẽ có một cái skill về notebook LM
research và sau đó là mình có cái skill
về
mình có một cái skill về làm slide.
làm slide, làm
infographic
thì cái cái workflow này của mình á là
khi mình nói về một chủ đề thì nó sẽ lôi
cái cái skill outline ra trước để nó
dựng outline. Sau đó rồi nó sẽ lôi cái
skill outline xong thì nó sẽ lôi cái
skill viết để nó viết. Viết xong thì nó
sẽ lôi về
cái nội dung thấy chưa?
Ờ về nội dung thì sau đó là mình sẽ
duyệt cái nội dung đó và nó ok thì bắt
đầu nó sẽ có một cái skill về public thì
nó sẽ public. Thay vì trước đây á mình
phải làm sáu bước thì bây giờ mình chỉ
làm một bước một gọi cái workflow đó ra
và ai nó sẽ tự làm để ra một cái sản
phẩm cuối cùng. Thì hiện tại bây giờ nếu
như mình mở cái
notebook lên
thì mọi người sẽ thấy là
đây
nó sẽ có một cái
cái cái mới nhất ở đạo hề.
Hay chưa? Chưa chưa nó chưa chạy.
Thì sau khi mình làm xong nó sẽ ra một
cái kế hoạch. Kế hoạch như thế này thấy
chưa? Nếu mình đồng ý thì nó sẽ chạy cái
kế hoạch này và lúc đó là nó sẽ tạo cho
mình những cái cái video và cái slide
cho mình. Thì đây là cái kế hoạch mà cái
workflow này nó tạo ra. Thì bước một nó
sẽ tạo outline này như thế nào, nó tạo
hình trình video như thế nào, tạo slide
như thế nào và nó lưu về ở đâu. Đó, nó
lưu về ở đâu? Thì nếu như mình đồng ý
với cái phương án này thì nó sẽ tiến
hành nó làm thì nó sẽ gọi những cái ai
mà liên quan tới notebook ra nó làm. Nó
gọi ra hết cái những cái mình có á thì
nó sẽ gọi ra nó làm nếu mình đồng ý.
chư. Còn nếu mình không đồng ý với
phương án này thì mình có thể thay đổi
không
Tú là muốn một bài học mới chẳng hạn
thì nó sẽ sửa cái kế hoạch này lại và nó
tạo một cái bài học mới cho mình. Vì đây
là nó đang dựa vô trong cái bài mình có
rồi và nó sẽ thay đổi. Đây nè các bạn
thấy nè. Outline khóa học biển nè thì nó
sẽ lôi nó sẽ lôi cái skill outline ra nó
làm nó sẽ làm cho mình thì mọi người sẽ
xem qua đây một chút mình sẽ thấy
đây thì nó sẽ lôi cái outline này là cái
outline này là một cái skill mà mình có
đó và cái infographic DNA để mình xác
định là cái phong cách thiết kế là gì
thì nó sẽ hỏi mình thấy chưa? Ví dụ như
là nó sẽ hỏi mình là cái khóa học này nó
cái bài học này mình làm thì nó sẽ nằm ở
trong cái bài tám hay là một cái bài
mới. Đó thì ví dụ như mình nói là
tạo bài mới
thì nó sẽ tạo cho mình một cái bài mới
luôn. Nó không liên quan gì những bài cũ
hết. Thì cái này nó nằm thành một cái
mình đã tạo thành một cái workf low rồi
nên do đó là nó sẽ cứ thế nó làm thôi.
Nếu mình đồng ý thì tí nữa mọi người sẽ
xem nó sẽ thay đổi cho mình. Đây
thì nó thay đổi hết đó.
Copy writing nè. Copywriting này là một
cái skill bên này. Viết khoa học thú
trình là một cái skill và sau đó là viết
chuyên nghiệp sẽ sửa lại cho mình đó. và
soạn thảo một cái audio script. Có nghĩa
là mọi thứ nó đều nằm ở trong cái
workflow hết. Và nếu như mình process
cái này thì nó sẽ chạy cho mình luôn.
Đó, nó chạy cho mình hết một cái
khóa học. Thì mọi người có thể xem một
cái demo ở đây. Thì đây là cái cái
chương trình mà mình làm, một cái bài
mình đang làm về siêu năng lực của các
cái loài cá. Thì toàn bộ những cái sản
phẩm ở đây là sản phẩm của antiravity nó
làm hết. Ví dụ như bài 1 là nội dung gì,
có code ID như thế nào, rồi nó sẽ đưa
hết như thế này và sau đó nó sẽ tạo cho
mình một cái infographic mà theo cái nội
dung mình yêu cầu. Đó, ví dụ như đối với
cá kiếm là như thế nào thì nó sẽ tạo
info cho mình luôn. Nó tự động làm, mình
chỉ duyệt thôi. Nếu như mà hình ảnh này
mình cảm thấy đồng ý, ok sử dụng thì
mình sử dụng. Còn nếu mình cảm thấy là
chưa được thì bắt nó làm lại đó. Bắt nó
làm một cái bộ infographic mới và sẽ tự
động làm.
Và nó tạo luôn cho mình một cái slide
giới thiệu về cái bài học đó. Ví dụ như
bài học của mình thì mọi người cũng sẽ
xem cái
phong cách đó. Thì các bạn anh chị thấy
là luôn luôn có một cái nhân vật gọi là
con cái con cá trình á thì nó giống như
một cái signature của mình chẳng hạn.
mình lấy tên là chú trình thì lấy cái
con cá trình nó làm cái signature. Thì ở
trong tất cả những cái slide, những cái
hình ảnh minh họa đều có cái ông cá
trình này. Đó
thì tất cả những cái này những cái mà
các bạn đang xem các anh chị đang xem
đây là
antiravity nó chạy hết.
Nó chạy hết cho mình và mình chỉ có là
cái việc con người á bạn nào hỏi cái gì
nhờ? Cái a
bạn nào hỏi về cái phần con người của
mình ở trong này đúng không?
Là mình sẽ phải
đọc
và mình kiểm chứng thông tin.
Đó mình phải đọc và mình kiểm chứng
thông tin. Thì
cái việc con người của mình đây là mình
thực thi, mình ra lệnh cho nó và nó sẽ
thực thi những cái mà mình sẽ không phải
làm nữa. Trước đây mình phải tự làm.
Thực ra để soạn một cái bài này đó là
mình ngồi phải hai ba ngày mới xong. Thì
bây giờ mình có thể ngồi khoảng một buổi
thôi là mình đã có cái cái cái
khung kiến thức rồi để mình làm. Thì tất
cả những cái sản phẩm này đó mình đưa
lên mình đưa lên trên web của mình nó sẽ
chạy lên trên
sau khi mình đọc cái lệnh là cost public
thì nó sẽ chạy cho mình chạy lên cho
mình cái nó đẩy lên hết luôn tại vì mình
đã làm là là
cái sản phẩm mà đưa ra á là nó theo cái
dạng
các cái blog khác nhau rồi ở trên trên
web của mình rồi trên cấu trúc của mình
rồi nên là nó chỉ cần đẩy lên thôi. Thì
cái
phần deploy á nó sẽ đẩy lên đẩy cái
thông tin của mình lên trên web thôi. Để
các bạn xem là đó. Ví dụ như một bài như
thế này, một cái bài học như thế này thì
sẽ có trong cái cái sản phẩm của mình á
nó sẽ có là nội dung như thế nào. Xong
rồi mình sẽ có infographic. Thì
infographic này là chính là cái
infographic từ
từ notebook nó lấy về nó tạo ra xong nó
tự tải về lưu máy mình luôn và mình sẽ
tự động đẩy cái hình này lên trên trong
bài luôn theo cấu trúc mà mình đã đã có
sẵn. Mình không phải làm nghĩa là mình
không làm cái việc là hình này lên nữa
mà nó sẽ tự nó đẩy lên luôn. Đó thì đây
là một cái sản phẩm cuối cùng và các bạn
hình dung á là
thì đây là trang quản trị
mình sẽ quản trị ở trong này thì trang
quản trị trong này nó sẽ theo ý của mình
thôi. Thực ra cái này hồi xưa mà nếu mà
làm những cái web khác thì mình không
không làm được đâu. Nhưng mà mình nói
với nó là tôi cần một cái trang về quản
lý khóa học hoặc là quản lý ai đang học
như thế nào thì nó sẽ làm cho mình. Thì
hiện tại ví dụ như những cái trang này
là mình sẽ nó sẽ thống kê cho mình là 30
ngày qua là có bao nhiêu người học đó là
mình đang có bao nhiêu học viên đó tới
ngày hôm nay là mình có 350 học viên đó
thì đang học những bài nào có nghĩa là
mình đây hết và cái cái việc ừ cái quản
lý khóa học của mình á thì mình không
không làm nhiều mình chỉ format lại thôi
còn lại là ví dụ như tất cả những cái
cấu trúc mà để hiển thị ra á thì ai thì
anti Gravity nó tự làm hết cho mình. Nó
sẽ đẩy lên hết là ví dụ bài 1. Các bạn
xem thử ra nha. Ví dụ như bài 1 mình
đăng lên. Có nghĩa là những cái thông
tin trong bài 1 này là nó nằm ở trong từ
cái workflow nó có rồi và nó đẩy lên
thôi. Mình không có gõ nữa, mình không
đánh máy, mình không làm bất kỳ một cái
gì. Mình chỉ sửa ở trên antiravity thôi.
Và antiravity sau cái bảng cuối cùng thì
nó sẽ đẩy lên trên này. Đó, tất cả những
cái nội dung, những cái format và những
cái hình ảnh thì antiravity đều đưa lên
trên này hết. Và sau khi mình chốt bài
thì mình chỉ
các bạn thấy là trong này nó có luôn
flash card ôn tập rồi qu kiểm tra. Thì
tất cả những cái này nó đều lấy từ
notebook của em hết.
đều nó qu hết và mình chỉ là cái người
đọc thôi và mình kiểm tra lại là đúng
hay chưa thôi. Đó ví dụ thông tin là
những cái câu hỏi qu này mình phải tự là
mình phải mình phải tự xem. Thì sau khi
xem xong thì mình public đó, mình public
cái
bài nó ra thì nó thành một cái sản phẩm
cuối cùng là cái bài học ở bên này. Đó,
thì sau khi mình publist xong thì sẽ có
cái bài học số 1 nó nằm bên này.
Đó.
Thì đây là bài học nó y như là ở bên kia
thôi. Bên kia nhập vô như thế nào thì nó
sẽ ra như như vậy thôi.
Đó về mặt hình ảnh tất cả mọi thứ thì
cái công việc của mình á
là mình đọc và cái thứ hai là mình chỉnh
sửa chính tả cho hình. Ví dụ như em cái
notebook của em thì về mặt chánh tả vẫn
sai, vẫn sai thì mình vẫn phải sửa. Thì
những cái bài đầu tiên á thì mình vì
chạy cho nó kịp giờ nên mình làm có một
số bài sai tả cũng khá nhiều. Các cháu
cũng nhắn tin là cháu ơi sai chỗ này sai
chỗ kia thì mình sẽ sửa. Đó
thì đó là cái việc của
mình.
Thì không biết là các bạn có cái
trao đổi gì không?
Chỉ có một lời khen sâu sắc là rất đẹp.
hình rất thích.
>> Dạ.
>> Hình chụp về sinh vật biển thì nó đúng
là rất đẹp. Không biết là à có thể là
chắc là cũng là hình ai hoặc là à
điều chỉnh thế nào nhưng mà nói chung là
rất là đẹp. Nhìn nó rất là chân thực.
>> Thì cái này à rồi à chị chị Phương phải
không ạ?
Chị tên Hương chứ không phải Phương.
>> Hương chị Hương.
Dạ
>> thì để cho mọi người để em trả lời một
số cái câu hỏi của mọi người ở đây thì à
ờ trước mắt trước khi mà ừ trả lời cái
của chị Hương thì ờ cái a
thực ra cái này nếu mà để làm ra một cái
chương trình một cái bài khoảng một cái
khóa học mà khoảng bảy bài á năm bài á
thì mình cũng phải mất đâu đó phải 10
ngày để gọi là hoàn chỉnh kể cả là làm
video. Thực ra cái video á cái video ở
đây là mình có một cái trick nhỏ nhỏ thì
mọi người có thể thử để mà đồng nhất cái
nhân vật á thì mình sẽ bắt nó vì sao
mình bắt nó làm cái slide cái slide á
cái slide deck của notebook á thì nó sẽ
giữ cái nhân vật khá là ok.
Sau đó mình lấy cái hình ảnh đó mình đưa
vào trong a
trong cái
VO3 á mình tạo hình ảnh tạo ảnh động cho
cái hình ảnh đó thì nó sẽ ra được một
cái video nhất quán một chút mỗi cái
clip khoảng 8 đến 10 giây thì sau đó
mình à mình lòng tiếng vào thôi. Lòng
tiếng cũng dùng AI thôi, cũng dùng cái
Google AI Studio mình cái mình học lớp
của Minh cũng của Minh để mình làm một
cái trang riêng tự làm cái
trang riêng cho cái đọc văn bản.
Ờ
notebook bản pro có kết nối được không?
Được hết. Có nghĩa là mình chỉ cần gọi
cái CLI của notebook vào thì mình cứ bảo
antiity là cài cái đó vào cho mình thì
nó sẽ làm.
Nhưng mà khi mà các anh chị mà dùng với
antiravity nó sẽ có một cái nhược điểm
là vì nó làm quá nhanh nó gọi một lần
thôi thì làm được tám hình thì hết cota
rất là nhanh. Hết quota của notebook á.
Như một ngày là của Pro nó cho mình 10
16 hay 17 cái infographic gì đấy thì chỉ
cần một lệnh của antiravity thôi. Mình
gọi là tạo cho tôi tám hình là nó chạy
một lần tám hình luôn. Mình không phải
chờ, mình không phải viết prom lại, mình
không phải chờ. Nên cái cái cái hết
quota của notebook nó rất là nhanh. Thì
đó là cái cái mà mình thấy là nếu mình
dùng antiravity là mình sẽ bị cái cái
chỗ đấy.
Cái database và mã nguồn thì như nãy anh
có nói thì anh lưu ở Superbase. Database
thì lưu ở Super Bay và cái host đang
chạy là của Vale, cái của Vale luôn cũng
cùng hệ thống trong cái hai cái hệ thống
đấy thì nó liên kết với nhau. mình lưu ở
trên đấy luôn thì nó
đỡ phải mua hostin bên ngoài. Tại vì
host bên ngoài nó không support ít cái
hosting nó support cái dạng mà web app
như thế này nên mình xài thẳng luôn của
của Vale với Superbe.
Thì phần quản trị này thì anti ra làm
hết a phúc.
Thực ra đầu tiên thì mình chỉ có một
phần nhỏ thôi là đăng bài, đăng khóa học
sau đó mình phát triển dần lên là mình
yêu cầu nó có thêm những cái những cái
tính năng mới. Thực ra thì cái này nó
hay ở cái chỗ là khi mà các bạn nói tính
năng á thì nó sẽ làm cho mình. Ví dụ
mình khi mình làm cái sản phẩm này và
mình đưa cho một cháu cháu xem thì cháu
nói là chú chú làm cho cháu cái hệ thống
chơi game đi.
Ờ thẻ game đi. Thì mình cũng chỉ nói với
anti Gravity là ta muốn làm cái hệ thống
thẻ thẻ game thôi. Sưu tập các cái thẻ
và sinh vật biển. Thì các bạn xem là nó
làm cái gì cho mình. Anti Gravity nó làm
gì cho mình. là mỗi ngày nó sẽ cho các
bạn quay một cái thẻ hiệu ứng đồ đẹp
lung linh đàng hoàng. Đó có một cái thẻ
đó thì khi mình xem thì nó sẽ có thông
tin về cái sinh vật biển đó thì cũng là
một cái cách để các bạn học. Và sau khi
mình làm xong những cái cơ bản thì mình
bắt đầu mình mới đi vào cái cái cái chi
tiết một chút. Thì để cho các bạn có khả
năng quay trở lại cái cái trang web của
mình thì mình làm cái hệ thống điểm. Sau
khi các bạn chơi xong, các bạn học bài
xong, các bạn thi kiểm tra xong thì các
bạn sẽ có điểm và sẽ có xếp hạng. Hiện
tại là cái điểm xếp hạng nó đang cũng
cạnh tranh rất là gây gắt. Các bạn vào
học rồi các bạn lấy điểm đó. Và các cái
bộ sưu tập thẻ của mỗi người thì nó đều
nằm ở trong cái
hồ sơ cá nhân. Thì tất cả những cái này
là antiravity nó làm hết các bạn. Mình
chỉ ờ cung cấp ý tưởng thôi. Đó mình chỉ
cung cấp ý tưởng thôi và nói là các bạn
làm antiity viết cho tôi đó.
Thì các bạn thấy là ví dụ như bộ sưu tập
của mình ở đây thì có sẽ có một số các
cái thẻ đó có loại quý hiếm rồi nói
chung là nó tự nó làm hết bạn mình không
có làm mình không có biết gì về code hết
trơn á thì mình nói là bây giờ làm cho
tôi một cái bộ chơi game như thế này thì
nó sẽ làm cho mình thôi và nó khuyến
khích là các bạn mỗi ngày các bạn đều
phải vào quay lại để mà các bạn quay lấy
cái thẻ đó có một số bạn cũng cứ quay ra
những cái bình thường đó chú ơi sao con
chỉ có quay ra mấy cái bình thường mà
không thấy cái hiếm gì hết á. Đó thì ví
dụ như là thẻ hiếm là cũng có rồi thẻ ờ
nó gây cho mình nó cái này gọi là game á
các anh chị để cho ví dụ như đây những
con cá hiếm thì nó sẽ có thông tin thì
các bạn xem con cá này các bạn sẽ đọc
được thông tin là con này sống ở đâu. Đó
một cách là mình gián tiếp mình cung cấp
thông tin về sinh vật cho cho các bạn
học sinh. Th ra người lớn thì có một số
anh chị lớn thì cũng thích vào đây để
học thì không học nhưng mà vào quay lấy
sẻ vật cho vui thôi thì nó cũng vui.
Ờ skill tạo giọng đọc AI.
skill tạo dòng đọc AI thì thực ra mình
học từ Minh á
mình à
đây
đây là cái
cái cái này là mình học từ Minh nè để
mình viết anh chị thấy là cái đuôi của
nó là vale chap á thì thực ra là mình
cũng nói ai cũng nói antiity viết cho
mình một cái
cái App thì để cho mọi người xem thì nó
nằm ở đây đó
nó cũng nằm trong này thôi anh chị. Mình
mình cũng chỉ kêu lên nó viết cho mình
một cái app thôi và đưa lên thì nó nằm ở
đây. Thì ví dụ như là mình nói đọc ha.
Mình thử ha. Nó giống như là Google AI
Studio mà mình viết riêng cho mình thôi.
Ví dụ như mình nói là giọng ngữ cảnh là
giọng nữ miền Nam đi ha. Rồi mình cho nó
đọc
thì nó
>> Minh Đỗ thiệt đẹp trai quá đi.
>> Có nghĩa là cái cái giọng này là của
trong mình có thể đổi giọng theo Google
AI à Google Studio đó hoặc là giọng nữ.
Cái này cái này là em sử dụng của cái
thằng Google.
>> Đúng rồi chị. Cái này là em dùng cái cái
mã nguồn của Google Studio. Có nghĩa là
nó cho mình đâu đó
ờ 25 cái giọng đọc thì mình sẽ có tự tạo
ra cái thực ra những cái video ở trên
cái trang của hả.org ORG đều đọc từ đây
đó thì mình sẽ lưu về
>> Minh Độ thiệt đẹp trái quả đi.
>> Đó thì giọng nam, giọng Huế, giọng miền
Trung hay là giọng nam, giọng nữ đều
được hết. Rồi tông cao nhanh chậm như
thế nào thì mình đều đều theo cái của
Google Studio thì chẳng qua là em viết
riêng ra để cho dễ dùng thôi.
>> Cái này em làm lại cái giao diện thôi
đúng không? Dạ đúng rồi. Thực ra để mình
tự mình dùng với lại em dùng cái credit
miễn phí mà nó cho mấy trăm đô mấy tháng
đó mà không biết giờ hết chưa em chưa
kiểm tra nữa thì em đang dùng nó miễn
phí thôi. Nó không tốn kém gì đây cả.
Thì thì cái này là cái mà mình đang dùng
để cho cái giọng đọc. Ờ ABI thì hiện tại
mình đang dùng miễn phí đó. nó cho mình
mấy trăm đô cái đợt đấy thì đang còn nên
mình xài thôi.
Đang bào đó mà không biết là nó tính
tiền hay chưa cũng chưa coi nữa.
Đấy thì hầu như là những cái gì mình
đang làm ở đây là Ai cái antiravity nó
đưa ABI.
Chị thấy có một cái của em
>> 300 đô trial á thì nếu mà em đã nạp cái
thẻ vào rồi á thì bây giờ em đi vào cái
đó em cancel subscription đi không là nó
hết.
>> Dạ biết. Dạ dạ biết em biết
>> cái gì vậy
>> rồi mọi người có
có cần trao đổi gì thêm như thế nào thì
cũng mạnh dạng nha còn sớm
>> anh trình đây anh trình cho em hỏi là
Trong lúc mà anh trình xây dựng lên cái
website này á để ra được một cái website
sản phẩm cuối cùng như vậy á anh trong
vòng 3 tháng thì cái khâu nào là cái
khâu mà anh text time nhất với lại nó
quan trọng nhất anh?
>> Ờ cái khâu mà thực ra cái khâu mà tốn
thời gian nhất là cái khâu mà mình phải
mình phải biết là cái cấu trúc cái cái
trang web của mình á là nó bao gồm những
cái gì á em. Ờ thực ra nếu mà không có
dùng những không phát triển những cái
phần mà game chơi game á cho học sinh á
thì nó rất là nhanh.
Nó sẽ nó về mặt cơ bản nó sẽ rất là
nhanh là chỉ cần là bài giảng rồi cần
trang viết đăng tin rồi trang quản lý
thì nó rất là nhanh. Còn cái phần mà khi
mà nó code cho mình những cái mà gọi là
liên quan tới tới game á thì mình phải
có một cái cái cái
tìm hiểu sơ sơ về nó một chút để mình
biết là ờ cái nào nó sẽ đi với cái nào.
Ví dụ như là mình tại vì khi mình trao
đổi với nó thì mình nó cũng sẽ gửi cho
mình luôn là cái user với lại cái điểm
nó sẽ nằm ở đâu, như thế nào để mình
cũng phải nắm chứ nhiều khi nó làm xong
mình không biết là nó nằm cái điểm nó
nằm chỗ nào để mình quản lý hoặc là mình
thật ra cái khâu khó nhất là cái khâu ý
tưởng là mình muốn làm cái gì và mình
phải trao đổi với nó.
bản thân mình phải hiểu câu hỏi đó đã
thì mình trao đổi với nó thì nó sẽ ờ
sẽ sẽ làm tốt hơn. Và cái khâu mà anh
thấy là nhiều nhất của mình ở đây đó
chính là cái khâu hoàn thiện cái bài.
Thực ra nói thì nhanh nó soạn bài ra rất
là nhanh nhưng mà mình hoàn thiện nó cho
nó chỉnh chu cho nó giống như bây giờ
giống như một số anh chị cũng khen rồi
vì nó chỉnh chu quá thì cái bài cái bài
nó để mà chỉnh chu thì nó nó tốn thời
gian thiệt. Thì nên một bài như vậy thì
hồi đầu mình cũng dự kiến là một tuần á
mình có một khóa học mới á nhưng mà
không làm nổi đó. Tại vì vừa đi làm mà
vừa làm cái này nữa thì ờ cái phần mà
cái phần cái khung nó có rồi và cái phần
mà mình chỉnh chu lại tới đoạn cuối á là
cũng tốn khá nhiều thời gian. Giống như
nãy chị Hương có hỏi là ủa hình ảnh nó
đẹp á thực ra thì nó cũng phải có mấy
phiên bản lận đó. Nó cũng có mấy phiên
bản.
Ờ
>> mà cái việc anh brainstorm lên cái ý
tưởng anh thì ban đầu chắc anh cũng phải
có một cái ý tưởng cơ bản nào đấy. Xong
rồi anh có dùng thêm AI gì để nó đào sâu
thêm để nó gọi mở cho mình thêm những
cái ý tưởng ờ sâu hơn không?
>> Thì thật ra thì cái từ cái ngày mình
có trước đây á là mình xài chemini á
mình chat nhiều nhưng mà sau có
antiravity là mình hỏi thẳng đó luôn.
Mình hỏi mình trao đổi thẳng luôn là bây
giờ tao muốn những cái vấn đề này, tôi
muốn chú muốn những cái vấn đề như thế
này, thế này thì nên phát triển như thế
nào thì cái việc của nó nó cũng sẽ đi
research, nó cũng tìm và sau đó là mình
cũng mình cũng sẽ đi tìm những cái trang
web. Thực ra cái mà anh hơi tốn thời
gian một chút nữa là anh đi tìm những
cái trang web mà về giáo dục
>> xong rồi anh lọ mọ để anh xem anh tìm
hiểu cách họ làm.
>> Họ làm xong rồi thì mình mới
>> mới ứng dụng vô cái của mình. Mình vô đó
để mình hình dung ra là cái sản phẩm đầu
ra nó cũng sẽ tương tự như thế nào đúng
không anh? Rồi mình quét tr lại nó đúng
không?
>> Thì mình sẽ hỏi lại nó giờ ta muốn ví dụ
em nếu như mà mọi người để ý thì mình sẽ
thấy có một cái
trong cái skill của mình á nó trong cái
cái bài học của mình á nó có cái phần là
nó có cái phần đây
nó có cái phần à trước khi bắt đầu đây
nè.
Thì cái này nó mình đi học từ một cái
bảo tàng khác thôi. Họ làm cũng làm họ
họ đánh vào cái câu hỏi là ờ gọi là
những cái sự thật mà hay bị hiểu lầm á.
Nỗi sợ khi nhắc đến là cái gì á. Thực ra
thì đây là một cái cái mà gợi mở cho cái
người học. Thì mình đi học từ người ta
xong rồi mình nói là ừ tôi muốn làm
giống vậy á. Thì bây giờ làm sao? Thì nó
sẽ gợi ý cho mình các bước để làm. đó
thì nó gọi cho mình cái cái cái cái để
mình làm thì thực ra cái time nhất là
cái đi research
cái mình đi tìm tìm hiểu á là nó có cái
gì để mình ứng dụng được á thì mà nó phù
hợp với mình, phù hợp với điều kiện của
mình thì thì ok thì nó tốn thời gian khá
nhiều. Còn cái đoạn mà code á thì AI nó
làm rất là tốt. Nó code rất là nhanh, nó
rất là tốt. Và sau đó mình có thể đối
chứng với nhau. Ví dụ mình dùng chemini
code nhưng mà dùng ông clot sau khi nó
bị bóp quá không có dùng clot nữa thì
dùng clot để code để kiểm tra lại thôi
là code nó ổn chưa. Kiểm tra lại chéo
với nhau vậy thôi. Hai ông cứ một ông
làm rồi một ông kiểm tra. Còn à
mình có hỏi a
có edit được không? Thì đây thì mình
edit bình thường. Có nghĩa là sau khi
bài vỡ mà lên rồi á thì mình chỉnh sửa
bình thường. Mình đổi tên đổi chữ bình
thường. Nếu mình cảm thấy cái câu đó dở
quá chưa hay thì mình có thể
có thể đổi nha Hùng.
Rồi có thể chèn thêm blog hình ảnh đồ
vào như thế nào, video vào như thế nào
thì tất cả là mình có thể sửa hết đó.
Mình sửa bài ở đây hết rồi mình lưu lại
thôi. Giống như trên WordPress thôi.
Ờ Khang có hỏi cái
thêm tính năng mới thì cái này chính là
cái cái mà mình rất là lo là khi mình
thêm một cái tính năng mới nó sẽ ảnh
hưởng tới cái toàn bộ hệ thống á. Do đó
là mình luôn luôn là thứ nhất là backup
và cái thứ hai đó mình dùng GitHub. Dùng
GitHub thì nó có một cái hay là nó sẽ
lưu những cái bảng cũ.
Khi nó publis một cái bảng mới lên mà
cái version mới nó bị lỗi thì mình sẽ
restore lại từ cái bảng cũ thì khá là
ok. Thì đó là lý do mình xài Ghup chứ
ngày xưa mà xài WordPress mà sai một
phát lỗi một phát là đi luôn thì cũng
rất là phiền. Quên backup một cái là rất
là phiền. Thì cái cái tính năng mới á
thực ra thì nên cái việc mà trao đổi
tính năng mới với antiravity á nó cũng
là một cái khoảng thời gian mà mình phải
trao đổi trước cái kế hoạch là sẽ làm
như thế nào thì mình phải đọc qua kế
hoạch đó trước. Nên thật ra mình cũng
không có phó mặt cho nó 100% là mày muốn
làm gì mày làm đâu nhưng mà mình phải
xem.
Ờ landing pay đúng không?
Ờ cái câu hỏi nếu nếu mà em sửa landing
bay thì em phải chat với anti đúng để em
sửa. Còn nếu làm website khóa học phức
tạp hơn thì làm thế nào để tối ưu? Ý là
tối ưu về mặt gì em?
À GitHub GitHub là một cái nơi lưu chữ
mã nguồn mở nha các anh chị.
thì nó là nó là github mình chỉ cần tạo
account thôi.
Ờ github cái vale và cái Superb là ba
cái trang mà mình có thể tạo tài khoản
miễn phí và sau đó là mình đưa cái
account đưa cái API cho
anti Gravity để nó kết nối ba ông này
lại với nhau. Thì Minh hay xài cái này
nhất nè. Cứ làm xong đóng gói đưa lên kí
hub rồi chia sẻ cho mọi người để mọi
người xài. Thì cái của mình nó cũng
thuộc dạng là mã nguồn mở nhưng mình
không open, mình chỉ xài cho riêng mình
và nó chỉ chạy trên trang web của mình
thôi. Mọi người không tải về được. Nói
chung là như Minh hay làm á, Minh làm
chia sẻ skill thì mọi người sẽ tải cái
skill đó về từ trang hub. Thì của mình
thì nó cũng thuộc dạng mã nguồn mở đó
nhưng mà mình chỉ xài riêng cho cái dự
án của mình thôi nên mình không có
public nên mình không có đánh giá, mình
không có ai vô xem được hết. thì nó nằm
ở trên GitHub thôi. Thì nó cho mình ờ
rất nhiều các cái phiên bản. Ví dụ mình
có phiên bản mới thì nó sẽ update lên
phiên bản mới. Rồi nếu như bị lỗi thì
mình sẽ restore nó về cái phiên bản cũ.
Thì mọi người có thể xem nó đăng đăng ký
ở
vithub.com.
Đó.
Còn Hương ơi, Hương hỏi tối ưu là tối ưu
gì Hương?
À có lẽ theo mình hiểu bác Trình ơi có
nghĩa là giữa cái trang landing B với
lại website á
>> mà website khóa học như cô bác á thì
trường hợp mà này mà thay đổi nội dung á
thì cái độ phức tạp rồi đó thì
làm như thế nào để cho nó tối ưu chỉnh
sửa
À thì cái này
>> tại vì landing bed là chỉnh sửa trực
tiếp trên cái ô chat của antiravity luôn
thì nó sẽ là ra được liền. Còn với cái
website này nó nặng đô hơn thì sao?
>> Thì đây thì đây ha. Ví dụ như bây giờ
mình có cái phần bài viết nè. Mình có
một cái phần quản lý bài viết thì nó sẽ
giống như là quản lý landing bay á. Cái
nội dung của landing bay thì để mọi
người xem cái bài viết nó.
Cái bài viết ha. Thể bài viết thì mọi
người xem là thì mọi người thì nó sẽ hay
ở cái chỗ là
đây là một cái bài viết nó gi tương tự
như landing bay mà mình làm thì nó nằm ở
trên hệ thống luôn. Thì trong này nó sẽ
có bố cục, nó sẽ có giới thiệu thông
tin. Ví dụ như tổng quan là con cá này
nó sống ở đâu rồi cấu trúc giải phẫu này
có nghĩa là từng cái block này là mình
tự thiết mình mình thiết kế được nha
Hương là mình muốn là ok mình muốn cái
cấu trúc giải phẫu này nó nằm ở block số
2 rồi tới hành vi sinh thái đúng không?
Tới cái thông tin này là tới thư viện
hình ảnh xong thư viện hình ảnh xong rồi
mới đến là những cái sự thật thú vị. Thì
cái bố cục này là do mình
do mình
mình bắt nó thiết kế thì
Antigravity nó sẽ thiết kế cho mình một
cái block. Thì ở đây á thì nó sẽ hay ở
cái chỗ là em sẽ tùy biến được rất là
nhiều.
Ví dụ như đây nè nó gọi là template thì
có nghĩa mình xây dựng cái template cho
cái bài viết luôn. Ví dụ bài viết sinh
vật biển là sẽ có một cái dạng template
khác. Bài viết về hả dương học nó sẽ là
một dạng template khác và bài viết top 5
sinh vật biển thì nó sẽ là dạng template
khác. Thì cái này mình sẽ tùy biến được.
Mình sẽ bắt ông antiravity á là viết cho
tôi cái template cho bài viết.
Đó thì để
Hương xem nè cái bài viết vừa rồi là cá
mập đúng không? những cái bài viết top 5
sinh vật biển hoặc là một cái cái nội
dung khác thì nó sẽ nó sẽ nó sẽ hiển thị
khác. Nó sẽ hiển thị khác.
Đây để mình cho mọi người xem
đây top 5 sinh vật biển thì nó sẽ hiển
thị khác với với
cái bài hồi nãy. Có nghĩa là cái này là
templete. Mình bảo anti gravity viết cho
mình một cái template về top 5 về thứ
nhất là ông nào sinh vật như thế nào.
Rồi tới thứ hai là con gì như thế nào.
Thì cái này là template về top 5. Ví dụ
như top 5 sinh vật biển sống lâu đời
nhất hay là top 5 sinh vật biển mà độc
nhất.
Đó thì đây là cái template về mặt cái
tùy biến là tối ưu cho cho mình á cho
cái dự án của mình á là mình bắt nó viết
template cho mình đó. Viết cho tôi một
cái template thì các anh chị thấy là hai
cái
hai cái thông tin là nó khác nhau. Nó có
template khác nhau. Thì hiện tại mình
đang có tới năm cái templet cho cái
cho cái cái cái của mình. Đó ví dụ như
là cái template về
những cái hiện tượng tự nhiên á thì nó
sẽ là màu trắng. Nó không có màu màu
dạng như thông tin nó không có màu đen
nữa mà nó cho mình mình cho nó màu
trắng.
Đây một dạng tin tức dạng bản tin thì
mình muốn nó màu trắng cho nó dễ đọc. Đó
thì cái này là template thôi. Thì mình
sẽ tùy biến. Ví dụ mình có ờ cái hệ
thống website của mình mình có 10 loại
bed thì mình làm năm cái 10 cái cái
template khác nhau và thông tin thì mình
sẽ tự sửa.
Thông tin thì mình tự sửa thôi. Ví dụ
như cái bài đó mình lên rồi mà mình cảm
thấy chưa đúng để mình nhanh nhất thì
mình tự mình sửa lại thôi. Đây thì mình
sẽ tự sửa trong này thôi. Đó mình sửa
lại thông tin trong này.
Đây mình có cái phần test mình tự sửa
hết. Ví dụ như cái chỗ này mình thấy sai
đến tả lỗi như thế nào đó mình sửa mình
sửa lại bình thường
mình tự sửa thì nó sẽ
thay đổi trên cái template của mình thì
thì đó là anh nghĩ là cái mà sẽ tối ưu
hơn cho
mình.
Đúng rồi. Đúng rồi. Thì dạng dạng là như
vậy đó.
Dạng dạng như vậy đó. Thì à
em sẽ mình sẽ thể hiện ra được là mình
có muốn show cái trang chủ của mình gồm
có 15 loại landing B hay không. Nó giống
như là nó giống như là em làm à bán
hosting chẳng hạn thì cái gói này nó có
landing B dạng này, gói kia Ling B dạng
kia.
Mình sửa trên cái trang quản trị luôn.
Ờ hình ảnh hình ảnh của khóa học là mình
tạo từ từ AI. Còn hình ảnh tự của của
thông tin á là hình ảnh thật nha các
bạn. Cái thông tin thì mình không có
muốn làm hình ảnh ấy nên mình làm hình
ảnh thật.
kiểm tra
ờ kiểm tra thông tin
thì thông tin là mình dùng notebook để
mình kiểm tra nha mọi người và mình nhập
cái nguồn cho nó. Thực ra thì ở notebook
thì mình phải
ờ trong cái câu lệnh của mình là mình đã
chốt cho nó cái nguồn những cái nguồn à
uy tín rồi. Mình không có cho nó tìm từ
các nguồn tiếng Việt. Mình chỉ sử dụng
các nguồn màn tiếng Anh thôi và các cái
trang web ưu tín như là National
Geographic nè, rồi những cái trang của
các nhà khoa học Mỹ. Thực ra mình là dân
khoa học nên cái nguồn thông tin á là
mình kiểm chứng rất là kỹ, mình không
có. Thật ra các bạn thấy là ở cuối
ở cuối mỗi bài đều có cái phần tài liệu
tham khảo à.
Đều có phần tài liệu tham khảo. Những
cái thông tin mình lấy ở đâu?
Ờ tạo trang quản trị riêng.
Trang quản trị này chỉ dành cho admin
thôi nha Hà ơi. Chỉ chỉ dành cho admin
thôi. Còn user là user là họ chỉ xem
được hồ sơ cá nhân thôi. Họ không vào
được trong này. User thì họ chỉ có cái
này thôi.
Họ chỉ chỉnh sửa được cái thông tin cá
nhân thôi.
Họ được chọn logo
hoặc là hình ảnh
avatar thôi. Còn họ không có được vào
trong cái phần kia, phần quản trị là chỉ
có admin thôi.
Ờ bằng em đăng ký một cái tên miền xong
em add cái tên miền nó vào trong V sale
là được
là chạy được. cái tên miền của mình.
Mình mua tên miền rồi mình gắn vào thôi.
Ah
ờ khi xây cái trang này á thì đầu tiên á
là anh anh làm miễn phí thì lúc mà mình
mới mở mình làm test á mình chưa đi giới
thiệu á chỉ có bạn bè mình vào á thì nó
ổn nó ổn tại vì nó cho mình đăng ký
account mới á của Super Bay á cái trên
cái database á là là 10 10 người mới một
một ngày. Nhưng mà khi mình lỡ tay mình
đăng cái bài này lên cái group
homeschool link á thì
mọi người ủng hộ quá, mọi người vào đăng
ký nhiều quá thì bị nghẽn, nó không cho
đăng ký mới. Do đó là mình phải
phải mua phải mua cái cái database và
mình chuyển thêm một cái a chuyển thêm
một cái bằng cách đăng ký nữa là một
cách đăng ký khá là hay. Nếu mọi người
sau này làm thì mọi người tích hợp nó
luôn ngay từ đầu. Đó là đăng ký qua
Google.
Thì cái này Vale nó cái Super Bay với
cái Vale nó cho mình làm. Thì mình thật
ra mình không biết làm đâu. Mình kêu là
bây giờ tôi muốn đăng nhập đăng ký tài
khoản mới bằng Google. Bằng Google thì
nó sẽ không bị nghẽn cái user đăng ký
mới. Thì lúc đó là mình chỉ đăng nhập
bằng Google thôi. Thì mình chỉ đăng nhập
vào cái
bằng email Google. Ai có Google là đăng
ký được và
xài luôn. không có phải đăng ký ngay từ
đầu nữa thì xài luôn bằng Google là
nhanh nhất. Và hiện tại bây giờ thì chị
Hương có hỏi thì đúng là bây giờ đối với
V Sale bây giờ em phải trả phí em phải
trả phí
20 đô một tháng để em chuyển nó về
server ở Singapore thì chạy rất là
nhanh. Nó không có hiện tượng lag nữa.
Tại vì v sale mà miễn phí thì nó nằm
server ở Mỹ thì em mới trả 20 20 đô. 20
đô một tháng để để có cái vale chạy. Thì
cái dự án bây giờ thì nói về kinh phí
thì cái vale 20 đô và cái cái Superb 20
đô là hiện tại mình đang tốn khoảng 40
đô một tháng cho cái dự án phi lợi nhuận
này.
Chắc cũng phải sắp sách chiếu ra đường
ngủ rồi.
Cái hosting hotinger nó không có hỗ trợ
cho cái dạng app này chị.
Thật ra em cũng có một cái host riêng á
nhưng mà vì nó không hỗ trợ cái app này
nên em phải chuyển sang cái này.
À về cái chỗ Khang có nói về cái tư duy
thiết kế và logistic thì cái logic thì
mình ok còn cái tư duy thiết kế thì nãy
tí nữa mình sẽ share cho mấy bạn hai cái
hai cái skill hai cái skill về thiết kế
ờ
nó sẽ khá là ổn. mình đang dùng đó là
cái Uxui
Pro Max với lại cái chống flop ở trong
chống slot vào trong thiết kế AI. Hai
cái cái cái skill khá là hay.
IBO là cái gì Thủy ơ
>> thì để anh khỏi cái xách chiếu ra đường
á.
>> Ibo thì lên sàn là có tiền.
Dạ tí em cho cái bộ skill á chị.
>> Trời chắc em xin anh của anh Trình hết
quá anh Đình ơi.
>> Khi sửa một thư mục nào đó trên trang
web thì chỉnh sửa trực tiếp. Chỉnh sửa
trực tiếp trên trang web luôn em. Tại vì
nó là nó là nó có database mà nên mình
chỉnh sửa trực tiếp trên trang web được
luôn. Thực ra cái này khi mình làm trang
web mình có cái admin á mình có cái
trang admin để mình làm thì mình chỉnh
sửa được hết. Mình sẽ chỉnh sửa tất cả
những cái gì mà mình cần cho cái a
cái trang của mình. Ví dụ như là mình
đang đang nói ví dụ như là ờ
bài viết về bài viết em sẽ có thư mục
gì? Ví dụ như sinh vật biển nè, à bài
viết về
ờ hiện tượng tự nhiên nè, rồi bài viết
về
về hệ sinh thái chẳng hạn. Thì về môi
trường chẳng hạn thì mình sẽ tạo ra
những cái cái thư mục đó và bài viết
mình sẽ bỏ vào trong đấy. Nó giống như
là một cái cuốn sổ của mình thôi. Mình
chỉ đặt qua chỗ nào đặt qua đặt về thôi.
Mình sửa được hết. Kể cả là các cái hệ
thống thẻ thì thẻ tên khoa học cũng vậy.
Em mình có thể tạo ra được cái danh mục
đó. Ví dụ như danh mục là thú biển là
thực vật như thế nào. Ví dụ em sẽ có
những cái category nó như thế nào thì
mình mình tạo được hết, mình làm được
hết. Có nghĩa là em muốn làm được cái
này thì em phải biết là ví dụ em muốn là
em muốn chỉnh sửa cái thư mục cho bài
viết thì em phải nói với anti gravity là
bây giờ ta muốn có cái phần để ta chỉnh
sửa cái phần thư mục này thì nó sẽ làm
cho mình. Thực ra cái này chính là cái
cái mà tư duy ban đầu để mình hệ thống
được với nhau á để link được những cái
công việc với nhau cho nó cho nó dễ cho
mình. Chứ nhiều lúc mình muốn cái này
nhưng mà nó không có trong hệ thống hoặc
là nó đang chưa có mình mình kêu nó làm
thì lại nó sẽ nhảy lung tung. Còn nếu
như mình mình làm từng bước một thì thì
nó sẽ mình sẽ nắm được cái cấu trúc và
cái
cái cái
yêu cầu để cho mình làm. Thực ra đầu
tiên là mình không có những cái mục này
nhưng mà qua lúc mình làm xong mình cần
biết là khi mình chạy rồi á khi mình
chạy rồi á thì user mới feedback lại cho
mình là đang bị lỗi này lỗi kia thì mình
mới sửa. Ví dụ như đầu tiên á là mình
không biết là mình không biết là user đã
bấm vào trong hoàn thành bài hay chưa.
Có những bạn họ không bấm nên họ không
biết là bài mình đã hoàn thành hay chưa
và không đi qua bài tiếp theo được. thì
mình phải ngồi lại, mình phải ngồi nói
chuyện với anti Gravity nói bây giờ cái
chỗ đó nó chưa nổi bật lắm, mình làm cho
nó nổi bật lên để mọi người xong bài là
mọi người phải click vào đó để mọi người
hoàn thành sang cái bài mới. Đó thì lúc
đó mình mới Rồi mình phải có cái bảng
xếp hạng để mình xem thử là ai đang ở
điểm bao nhiêu như thế nào. Đó thì thì
mình vẫn phải làm đó. một số bản xếp
hạng bây giờ là
các bạn anh chị thấy là cũng mọi người
cũng đua top liên tục vô có bài mới là
cũng vô làm lấy điểm xong rồi họ vào
hàng ngày họ truy cập hàng ngày để họ
đọc bài đọc tin thì
rồi sau đó thì sau khi mà mình có cái
sản phẩm rồi bây giờ mình muốn a mình
muốn nó
được Google tìm kiếm thì lại phải đưa
vào trong Google Analytics để cho nó
tính toán thử là 1 tháng anh có bao
nhiêu người dùng, người ta dùng ở đâu
đó, tỷ lệ out ra là bao nhiêu thì thật
ra để mình làm cái kế hoạch lâu dài như
thế nào thì thực ra cái này nó cũng ờ
cũng cũng có một chút kiến thức về cái
này một chút xíu. Mình cũng không rành
về cái này nên cứ phải ngồi với
antiravity để kêu nó hướng dẫn rồi nó
làm cho mình. Đó thì ví dụ như là một 1
tháng vừa rồi là mình có 5000 được xem
rồi họ ở lại bao nhiêu. Ví dụ như là đó
mình trung bình là một cái người vào họ
ở lại trang web mà 7 phút 6 phút là là
khá là ok. Đối với một trang web mà họ
vào xong họ ở lại khoảng 7 phút thì mình
nghĩ là nó cũng là khá là ổn.
Rồi
tiến độ mình cũng muốn biết là học viên
học hành như thế nào thì mình vào mình
xem thử là là học viên đang học như thế
nào. Bài này thì ví dụ như bài này thì
có bao nhiêu người học. Đó cái này là có
nghĩa là khi mình làm rồi á mình cứ trao
đổi với với anvity thôi là bây giờ mình
có hệ thống rồi bây giờ là cho tôi cái
bảng này để tôi theo dõi là ai đang học
đó. Ví dụ như bạn Long này bạn hoàn
thành cái lớp này cái bài học này rồi
hoàn thành rồi. Bạn nào đang học thì đều
có đó.
Thì nó là như vậy.
>> Đối tượng của những người vào trang web
này là ai anh?
>> Ờ hiện tại thì à
hiện tại thì à đối tượng là
từ Facebook khi mình share đó đối tượng
là học các bạn. Bây giờ các bạn học sinh
hiện tại bây giờ mình đang có là ờ người
dùng ha người dùng
mình đang có 218 học viên và 72 phụ
huynh. Thì phụ huynh là những người mà
đăng ký cho con mà học. Còn học viên này
thì cũng là chắc là cũng phụ huynh đăng
ký thôi nhưng mà họ dùng tên của để cho
các bạn tự vào các bạn học thôi. Thì
mình đang có phụ huynh học kèm chung với
chắc là các bạn nhỏ thôi.
Ờ dùng notebook.
>> Một môn học trên trường hả anh? Nó là
một môn học trên trường hay sao ạ?
>> Không, cái này nó không liên quan gì tới
trường cả. Cái này nó chỉ là
ờ
cái này nó chỉ là là
anh làm chia sẻ kiến thức sinh vật biển
thôi. Còn không liên quan gì tới các cái
bài thực ra thì
>> không liên quan tới các bài học trên
trường
>> nhưng mà sắp tới thì anh đang sẽ làm
việc với một số các cái giáo viên để cái
môn tự nhiên á những cái bài nào mà nó
liên quan á thì anh có thể xây dựng cái
bài đó rồi cho các bạn cô có thể giới
thiệu cho các bạn vào các bạn học các
bạn xem thêm.
Ờ dùng notebook em có tạo được chức năng
của nó không? có tạo full
ờ cái cinematic thì không chưa được nha
Bảo ơi. Ờ
infographic thì thoải mái. Thật ra thì
infographic slide slide thì cũng chỉ làm
được ở mức độ là mặc định thôi, không
làm được chế độ dài. Chưa cái cái cái
bản mới nhất á thì nó chưa cho mình làm
cái đó.
Ồ có phúc hai bé đang học trên này à.
Ờ duyệt trước layout có nha Khang.
Thực ra là cái này trước khi publist á
thì nó mình chạy local hot để mình xem
trước.
Mình mình chạy local hot thì mình xem
trước cái giao diện rồi tất cả mọi thứ
rồi mình chỉnh sửa. Ờ còn chị Hương hỏi
cái bộ màu á thì thực ra là
thực ra là nó như thế này vì em có cái a
thực ra là tất cả các skill mà đưa về
đây em dùng á em dùng cho dự án này á nó
đều phải
follow cái ru của em
sau này nó thay đổi hết là nó thay đổi
phù hợp với cái
cái cái của mình mình đã có em định hình
cho nó cái style trước rồi mà em không
nhớ giờ không nhớ nằm ở đâu.
Ờ
em có quy định cho nó một cái style
trước rồi nên nó sẽ làm theo cái style
màu của em.
Ừ
không nhớ giờ không nhớ nằm ở đâu nhiều
quá
à đây brand nó không nó có cái nó có một
cái friend gueline. Thực ra cái này đầu
tiên mình phải có một cái brand guine
cho nó luôn á. Chị Hương
em để nó ở đâu rồi?
Ờ
đại system đây
đây chị.
Thì cái skill mà trên mạng họ đưa về á
thì em bắt nó phải tích hợp chung với
cái style của mình. Thì ở đây là cái
design test này á là cái hương vị của
ông Trình. Ông Trình ông sẽ theo cái
giao diện mặc định là màu gì. Rồi nền có
nghĩa là cái này bọn em em đã có sẵn
rồi. Em đã xây cái guine trước rồi. Em
có một cái guine trước cho nó thì sau
này nó sẽ đi theo cái
tông màu này. Thì ok em cũng sẽ share
cái này để cho chị về chị
làm cho nó phù hợp với
yêu cầu của mình thôi.
Thì cái này em sẵn sàng chia sẻ thôi.
Thực ra là mấy cái skill mà UI UX Pro
Max đó là
nếu mà mọi người không có một cái ừ
brand guy hay là cái style riêng thì cơ
bản mang về cũng vứt. Nó chỉ chẳng qua
là làm cho cái trang của mình nó
nó đẹp hoặc là nó nó gọi là ừ đi chuẩn
hơn tí xíu nhưng mà về cơ bản là nó vẫn
bị ai hóa
100% luôn. Nhìn gần như là tất cả các
trang nếu làm dựa vào cái skill đó. Thật
ra cái cộng đồng nếu mà anh chị mà tham
gia nhiều trên antiravity hoặc anh em mà
làm về code thì anh em cũng nói rất là
nhiều về vấn đề này. Dùng ra 100% dùng
cái skill UIX đó mà không có guine là
thua hết. Ra trang web na ná nhau hết,
số hóa hết.
Cho nên phải có cái bảng
Ral giống như của bác Trình.
Ờ chị Hương có biết cái trích mà đi chôm
chỉa không? Đi chôm chỉa style không?
Ờ
chị thì thường làm chôn bằng cách là
chụp hình lại kêu
chess CVT nó móc tách thành Jason à. Thì
>> đúng rồi đó. Thì thì em nói bây giờ chị
cứ đưa cái trang của em vào k mày cho
cái bộ màu của cái này nó làm. Thực ra
thì
>> tuy nhiên tuy nhiên nhá chị thấy đánh
giá rằng là à mặc dù là cái thằng
chestvt nó làm
tốt hơn cái thằng seminar nhưng mà à nó
vẫn có những cái nó vẫn không ra được
đúng.
>> Dạ.
>> Đúng.
Ví dụ như chị cũng làm cái màu màu này
gọi là màu này màu này là màu blue nhưng
mà blue của blue hour là cái cái này nè.
Thì
>> nó ví dụ như giờ chị chụp cái hình này
của em đi không? Chị bóc tách nó vẫn
không ra đúng nó
nó ra nó vẫn không đúng được
cái cái độ nhẹt hoặc là nó nó vẫn là cái
tông màu blue power đó nhưng mà nó vẫn
không không chính xác được đâu.
>> Ừ.
Tuy nhiên thì khi giống như em nói đó,
khi mà mình kêu hàng AI nó tạo lại hoặc
là ấy này kia thì vô tình tạo nhiều lần
thì nó có thể nó sẽ ra được cho mình cái
tấm hình mà mình
>> ưng ý cái bộ màu ấy.
Còn thật ra có một cái mà nãy giờ mọi
người khen á ở chỗ cái bộ màu với cái
chỗ slide á thì mọi người có thể thử
cái này á bây giờ mà chia sẻ là coi như
là
ruột gan rồi đó nghe.
Cái mà chị thấy đẹp nhất á là ngoài cái
bộ màu là chính là cái
cái cái những cái con sinh vật biển này
nè. Nó vẽ nó nó rất là đẹp theo kiểu
chân thực. Tại vì chị cũng vẽ những con
này
>> thì chị chị cũng đang làm a những cái
con con như thế này nên chị chị biết.
À có một cái nữa là cái cái antigravity
này nó giúp cho mình cái dự án này của
mình nó có một cái tiện hơn. Đó là nếu
mọi người mở cái trang hả.org á mà trên
iPhone hoặc là trên máy tính mà ngày đầu
tiên lần đầu tiên á sẽ có một cái là cài
đặt cài đặt trên thành một cái dạng app
á. Ví dụ như là đây nó sẽ có một cái dấu
trên này. Open inap thì nó sẽ là nó sẽ
không ở cái dạng là trang web nữa mà nó
sẽ lưu về thành một cái icon ở trên máy
để sau này nó giống như một cái app vậy
đó. Mọi người không cần phải mở cái
Chrome hay cái gì lên nữa để mọi người
xài nữa mà cái này nó gọi là
DW
A
DV WBA à
nó là một cái dạng mà chuyển cái trang
web của mình cái mình đang dạng web app
thì nó sẽ chuyển thành nó sẽ có một cái
tính năng để mà nó chuyển thành thành
lưu vào trong máy luôn có thể chạy
offline được nó có thể chạy được nó sẽ
lưu lại nó là cái WVA
Thì nếu mọi người mở cái hạ trình.org ở
trên a
á đầu tiên á nó sẽ có gợi ý nữa mọi
người cài thì sau đó là nó cài vô máy
luôn. Mình không có làm app qua app qua
cái cái Apple Store vì không thể nào
đăng ký được cái cái việc đấy nên đang
lag đi một cách là bằng à cái này thì
anti Reality nó viết cho mình luôn. nó
viết nó nằm ở trong cái
cấu trúc của web luôn để khi mà mọi
người cần thì mọi người tải thành cái
app mọi người dùng ở trên máy luôn không
cần phải vào trong trình duyệt nữa.
Kể cả là quản trị luôn chứ bằng trên cái
app nó cũng được.
À kỹ năng chôm chỉa đó như nãy gì Hương
nói á thì thật ra mình hay chôm chôm
theo kiểu là mình lên Pinterest mình tìm
những cái hình ảnh rồi những cái mã màu
mình thích xong rồi mình lại nhờ
với chat GBT nó phân tích cái brand cái
brand của cái hình đấy thì nó sẽ cho
mình là mã màu rồi tương phản như thế
nào tất cả mọi thứ rồi mình mình đưa cái
đó vào mình dùng ở trong cái a
cái a
cái design của mình. Thì hiện tại bây
giờ á ở trên Facebook của mình và những
cái bài
nó có nhiều cái style lắm nhưng mà thực
ra thì mình thấy là cái việc mình viết
prom á nó sẽ không bằng thằng antiravity
trong a
trong trong
antiravity á khi mình nói là viết cho
tao một cái DNA thiết kế là mọi người
dùng cái từ này nha
ra DNA
và sau đó là mọi người dùng cái cái cái
prom mà nó tạo ra á để mình đi tạo ra
những cái cái sản phẩm của notebook á nó
sẽ rất là đồng bộ. thì để mọi người xem
qua một cái cái của của mình
thì mình có rất là nhiều cái phong cách
thiết kế mình dùng để mình test thử. Ví
dụ như là một cái cái cái
DNA thiết kế thì mình ghi là phong cách
Roblox chẳng hạn thì là cái game mà con
gái mình nó hay chơi ở nhà á. Mấy đứa
nhỏ chắc nó hay chơi ch mọi người cũng
biết. Thì nó sẽ tạo cho mình những cái
bài học mà những cái hình ảnh nó liên
quan là nó rất là đồng bộ với nhau. Còn
cái mà màu sắc mà mọi người đang thấy
đẹp đó thì đây là cái keyword.
Đây là cái keyword cho mọi người.
Cái này mình lấy cảm hứng từ một cái
kênh YouTube
là phong cách
này của ông Đức hay sao ấy. Ui gì đó khó
đọc quá chả nhớ.
Thì tất cả những cái bài những cái hình
ảnh mà mình dùng cho fanpage thì nó sẽ
cái bài vừa rồi mình làm cái slide trình
chiếu á là cũng theo cái cái cái phong
cách này. Đó thì
đó cũng khá là khá là vui
đó. Màu sắc nó rất là kiểu rất là nhộn,
phù hợp với trẻ con. Mặc dù mình biết là
cái fanpage mình chia sẻ thì các mẹ đọc
là chính nhưng mà thôi thì làm tới đâu
hay thế đó.
Còn cũng có những cái phong cách khác ví
dụ như là phong cách này là phong cách
của
Ngo
thì để mọi người xem cái Ngo này nó nó
như thế nào. Đó, rất là rất là đẹp.
kiểu long lanh lấp lánh hơi nó hơi chân
thật một chút.
Thì riêng về cái notebook mà ngồi mà làm
về các cái phong cách thiết kế thì nó
cũng khá là mất thời gian cũng khá khá
khá nhiều thời gian á. Mọi người đã bao
giờ mọi người làm cái slide trên
notebook mà slide dọc chưa?
Đây
đây là slide dọc nha mọi người.
Đây là một cái trick mà chắc là chỉ có
mình mình làm thôi chứ chắc chưa ai làm
là làm slide trên notebook của em nhưng
mà làm slide dọc để chi mọi người biết
không? Mọi người đoán thử xem thử là cái
này để mình làm cái gì biết không?
>> Video bác chị
>> video
>> đúng rồi
>> Facebook.
>> Cái này mình sẽ làm thành video real.
Đó, nếu như mình dùng cái này, cái này
nó có trước cái đang làm cái sót nha
Minh nên tôi là tôi nghĩ là tôi
lắp tụi nó trước một bước.
>> Đâu bác làm sao? Thì đây là đây là cái
video ngắn màysez
lowers
1.8° and that surface ice actually acts
as a thermal blanket blocking out the
freezing air to maintain a hidden liquid
haven. Next, the summer banquet. After
months of pitch plaque, continuous
summer sunlight triggers a massive
phyoplankton bloom. This glowing
underwater meadow summons billions ofill
and apex predators for a concentrated
feeding frenzy. Third, extreme biology.
Meet the Antarctic ice fish swimming
flawlessly in subzero waters. It
survives using completely transparent
blood packed with a nitral antifreeze
protein so it never turns to ice.
Finally, the global connection. When
polar water does freeze, it pushes out
the salt. This creates heavy sinking
water that drives a global ocean
conveyor belt regulating weather for the
entire planet.
empty was highly adted biological
engines
climate ticking
đó thì đây là cái cái mà mấy ổng mới
làm thêm thì mình giới thiệu cho mình vô
mình thử phải cài đặt user ở tiếng Anh
thì nó mới có cái này. Thì tiếng Việt nó
không có.
Cái cinematic cũng có tiếng Anh thôi
nhưng tiếng Việt thì không có. Đúng rồi.
Ừ. Nhưng mà cái slide là dạng dọc là
trick gì?
>> Trick hả? Đây ng theo kích thước 96.
>> Ừ.
Đây là à thì cái chỗ video mọi người có
hỏi á thì nó cũng nó cũng thực ra là
mình làm nó không có chuyên nghiệp đâu.
Cái này phải học cái chỗ thủy với với
bảo hôm trước cơ chứ còn cái này là mình
chỉ đang làm là mọi người lấy cái hình
đó mọi người lấy cái hình trong cái cái
not của em á thì mọi người bỏ vào đây bỏ
vô cái cái flow á cái lab của Google á
ha. Thì ví dụ cái hình á ngày xưa mình
làm cái hình nó nó hơi nhiều chữ thì cái
bảng này cũ cái bản mới đây mới làm thử
thì thực ra nó nó một cái cái cái rất là
đơn giản thôi.
Ờ đây
thì mình lấy mình lấy hình ảnh ở trong
cái đây là hình ảnh ha. hình ảnh xong
rồi mình chỉ làm một cái câu lệnh xong
rồi mình
à
biến cái hình ảnh nó thành ảnh động
thôi. Đây là mình dùng có tạo ảnh động
nè. Xong rồi mình copy cái câu lệnh vào
đây là chuyển động cái này thì nó sẽ tạo
ra cái ảnh động và sau đó dùng canv ghép
lại thành video. Đó mình cảm thấy khá
khá ok.
Xong rồi mình lại ghép cái đóng slide đó
vào trong Canv á thành một cái cái cái
cái
video.
>> Em là em là em cho tải cái này về xong
em cho nó bố anti nó tự tự ghép thành
một video luôn. Mình không phải tự ghép
nữa.
>> À thế à.
>> Dạ
>> tại vì anh còn cái file voi nữa mà.
Voi nó ghép được anh luôn. Anh thử nhưng
mà ý là được nó có m được voi với hình
không?
>> Có.
>> À
>> nó đọc được. Cái này là một cái tool rời
mà em làm như trong cái tool mà anh bảo
làm thì nó làm được chức năng này nhưng
mà mình tự kêu nó làm được. Làm rất là
nhanh.
Thì anh báo anh biết là những trong cái
cái
video này à ừ cái cái cái em có một cái
tool để tạo cái video như thế này. Ngoài
cái tool tạo ảnh á thì nó sẽ tạo những
cái video như là 4 giây, 6 giây, 8 giây,
10 giây chứ không phải cái nào không
phải cái nào cũng cũng 10 giây nhá.
>> Xong rồi nó nó khi nó tạo xong rồi thì
nó sẽ tự tải về.
tự tải về thì cái tool của mình ở trong
đó nó sẽ kiểm tra là tải về chưa, tự lấy
nó ghép lại nó có thể tự sinh ra cái bộ
câu hút cho anh luôn. Ví dụ cái hút mà
anh muốn cho nó nằm chính giữa như thế
nào á.
>> Ừ
>> thì tự nó dán vào cho cái video cho đến
thành phẩm cho anh luôn.
thì anti làm được cái này. Anh chỉ cần
làm cái template mà nó ok và thiết kế
thiết kế cho ra được cái cái tempột mà
nó đồng bộ á thì nó làm được luôn.
Ủa nhưng mà nó làm một cái video như vậy
là chi phí như thế nào? Bao nhiêu em? Ví
dụ như video mà một thầ là chi phí bao
nhiêu
>> không? Trong gói Ultra nó tự làm chị chả
thấy tốn chi phí vô em cái gói Ultra em
với anh bảo xài đã thấy có bao giờ
không thấy hết
>> không thấy
>> nó làm nó làm ghép ra video đô hành
chỉnh luôn á là không
>> đô hành chỉnh luôn em đâu có dùng API
đâu đúng không em
>> không không có dùng API em dùng cái tài
khoản Pro của Ultra thôra thôi thì nó tự
làm
>> à sáng
Cái thời lượng video nó ngắn thì nó nó
ok chứ nếu mà mình làm thời lượng video
dài thì dài thì cái tool của anh Bảo làm
chị muốn xài bao nhiêu cũng được. Tool
mới có đấy ạ. Video dài.
>> Còn nếu mình làm res mà 1 2 phút thôi nó
đều làm được
ghép lại.
>> Đế b nào dạy dạy kèm nhá.
Anh làm được web này thì cái đó chỉ
chuyện nhỏ.
>> Anh làm được mà ý là anh có có anh chưa
làm được video. Thật ra anh đang bị anh
bị kẹt ở đây nè. Anh đang bị
>> Dạ đổi đổi anh đổi em có em không có mấy
cái món đồ chơi của anh chứ. Em xin đổi.
>> Ok thôi anh em ở trong nhóm không biết
là còn ai có thắc mắc trong cái buổi
chia sẻ của anh Hải Trình không? Nếu mà
có thì mình cứ đặt câu hỏi đi mọi người.
Không biết là anh Hải Trình còn cái phần
nào chưa chia sẻ không ta? Ông nay là
hết hết hết ruột gang chứ hết rồi hết
ruột gang rồi đó.
>> Vậy thì anh chị mà nãy giờ đang còn ngồi
ở đây thì có chắc bây giờ mình đặt câu
hỏi luôn hả anh hả? Ừ đặt câu hỏi thôi
mọi người cứ đặt câu hỏi
>> ok vậy thì mọi người cứ mạnh dạnng đi
mọi người m mình bút minh 3 tiếng lận
như không có cho minh bữa trước mới 10
giờ là ông ổ cắt rồi giờ
>> bữa nay ông ông trình ổng ổng nói rồi mà
ổng nói là cho tôi 3 tiếng nha chứ không
có chơi.
Trình ơi cho em hỏi anh chút. Hồi nãy
anh đang nói dở cái khúc hồi nãy em nghe
chưa có hết á là lúc mà anh tạo mấy cái
video hồi nãy á là anh xài notebook theo
em xong là anh tạo ra mấy cái hình đó
rồi anh vô Google xong rồi chuyển động
vô Canva xong mình nối mấy cái video đó
lại. Đó là trình thủ công á.
>> Dạ. Dạ. Em em cũng hay làm kiểu đó đó
nhưng mà về cái phần mà tạo tiếng xong
rồi anh lòng ghét như thế nào vậy anh?
Vô khá là anh làm thủ công á hả?
>> Cái tiếng với lại
>> không đây mình chỉ lại phải
trút ruột gan nữa rồi.
>> Em cảm ơn rất nhiều.
>> Chỉ cho mọi người một cái skill
là cái chem cái chem của Chemini ha. Thì
mình làm một cái chem là chích xất test
và tạo audio transcript. Thực ra cái này
là lúc là mình đang làm là mình làm cho
cái Canva á nhưng mà vừa rồi mình làm
cái cái full build cho cho cái workflow
là nó có luôn. Thì mình lấy cái file PDF
mà cái slide mình tạo ra á trên notebook
á
thì mình up nó mình tạo một cái chong
cái ch này có nghĩa là cái ch này mọi
người có xài cái ch này không?
Thực ra cái này là nếu như mà mọi người
dùng là nó sẽ cũng khá là hay á.
Mọi người có xài cái này không?
>> Chắc là ít người bác Trình ơi.
>> Ừ.
Qui
>> cái của mini á là nó
sẽ dành cho những cái việc mà các bạn sẽ
các anh chị mà làm cái việc mà lặp đi
lặp lại mà nếu mình chưa xài Ultra mình
chưa xài antigravity á hoặc là mình chưa
xài cái AI á thì mình dùng cái này.
Thì cái này nó cũng giống như là một cái
prom nhưng mà cái prom này đó là mình sẽ
dùng mình chỉ cần bấm vào cái tram này
thôi và mình làm mình đúng một cái thao
tác của mình thôi thì nó sẽ xử lý. Thì
cái tram này của mình á là mục đích mục
tiêu là chích xất văn bản từ cái tệp PDF
là cái tệp đó là cái tệp mà mình lấy từ
Nob á mình đưa nó vào đây và sau đó là
mình đưa cái
câu lệnh vào đây. Cái cái audio
transcript của mình á là mình muốn là
cái gì? Độ dài bao nhiêu mình đưa vào
đây nha. Mình đưa vào đây thì sau đó
mình
cũng nói thẳng luôn với nó luôn là tối
ưu video để làm âm thanh là để làm cho
cho cái
phong cách ngôn ngữ như thế nào, độ dài
bao nhiêu. Thì lúc đó là mình thì thì
thì mình mới đưa cái file mà PDF mà mình
lấy từ nút OM này bỏ đây nó chạy ra cho
mình cái audio Transcrip. Xong rồi mình
lấy cái audio đó mình mình bỏ vào trong
cái a cái trang web nãy mình làm để mình
đòi lòng tiếng á mình bỏ vào đấy cho nó
tạo
phải đọc thì đâu đó khoảng a
ok ok để để mình gửi cho
mình thật ra thì cũng chả có gì hay ho
đâu mình chia sẻ hết
đó thì nó sẽ ra cái audio transcript
xong rồi mình lại bỏ vào cái tool kia
cho nó đọc nó đọc xong rồi mình lại vứt
vào canv rồi mình à cân đối lại độ dài
thôi.
Thì nên cái hôm mà học bài của nghe cái
buổi của Thủy với Bảo thì người ta cũng
cũng không nghe được full nên không a
chưa biết ứng dụng như thế nào chứ còn
mình đang tốn thời gian nhất là cái
khoảng làm video này. Th ra lúc mình làm
trên Google Flow thì chữ tiếng Việt cái
đợt mà trước khi có cái Omni á thì tiếng
Việt cái chữ bị lỗi suốt à bây giờ thì
ổn rồi không thấy nó lỗi nữa. Ít lỗi hơn
n cứ mỗi lần lỗi phải làm tới làm lui
làm lại thì rất là tốn thời gian.
>> Em nghĩ là anh mất công cho cái phần t
này cũng kha khá rồi. Thì cái phần kia
thì tụi em làm ra rồi mà
>> đâu cần ai làm thêm đâu.
>> Nhưng mà hôm bữa có có chia sẻ cái tun
chưa? Chưa đúng không? Có thôi anh
>> có hả
>> ý nói là hai người là trao đổi
>> bí kiếp
>> ý ý là bây giờ anh đã có xuột hết rồi
giờ tụi em có tool rồi anh sẽ bỏ vô
thôi. Anh dành thời gian để nghiên cứu
cái khác đi.
>> Rồi ok.
Cái này thì nói thêm cái chỗ G này tí
xíu. Thật ra là chỗ cái cấu trúc mà cái
instruction này thì chỗ bác hãy trình
chắc chuẩn bị xare đúng không? Xare cái
này hả? Nhưng mà có nghĩa là nếu mà
những bạn nào mà chưa dùng về cái Zem
này á nói cho những bạn chưa dùng thôi.
Hiểu cơ bản là giống như chatbot của
chat GBT GBT hiểu cơ bản là như vậy
thôi.
>> Bên JPT thì mình vô mình tạo chatbot.
bên như thế nào đó instruction nếu mà
mọi người đã làm rồi thì bên này nó
tương tự như vậy thôi chẳng qua là nó
giao diện khác
và cái bên này thì nó được cái nó hỗ trợ
nhiều hơn những cái tính năng ví dụ như
ở đây là công cụ mặc định thì ở đây nó
có phần canvas thì cái phần canvas này
nó mới làm được cái việc đó ví dụ ở
trong cái
tính năng nó còn nhiều cái tính năng
khác nữa mình có thể chọn chuyên về
chatbot tạo hình ảnh chatbot
à tạo content hoặc là chatbot vừa
content vừa chữ a vừa hình ảnh vừa chữ.
>> Thằng thằng thằng thằng Z này nó có
nhiều cái hay.
>> Đây đây nè. Đó ví dụ như mình mình up
cái file up cái file
PDF lên xong rồi
nó sẽ hỏi là mình là muốn làm video dài
hay video ngắn?
Video ngắn thì nó cho mình kịch bản âm
thanh video ngắn
khoảng 3 phút thì mình dùng cái này xong
rồi mình chỉnh sửa trên cái kịch bản này
rồi cho nó đọc.
đọc xong rồi mình lại đưa vào trong kia
trong Canva để mình
làm thôi.
Đấy thì cái này là cái coi như là à có
cái này à Vũ hỏi gì hỏi đi Vũ ơi.
>> Rồi chào anh Trình Minh à cảm ơn rất
nhiều.
>> Dạ. À thật ra thì mình thì không có
chuyên về thẩm bẫy lắm cho nên là mình
cũng chơ chắc là phải phải tìm hiểu thêm
về mấy cái skill về làm USUi. Giờ thì
hôm nay chú ý mình mình nghe thì mình
đang link đến cái dự án mình đangnh làm
nó link với lại notebook nhưng mà nó lại
thêm một cái góc độ khác hơn. À tức là
mình không có có tận dụng cái artifact
của mà mình muốn tận dụng cái cái
knowledge ở trong đó.
Thì lúc trước mình tức là ý là mình làm
một cái LMS mà dạng ghi trên chatbox cho
học viên á. Ừ. mà mình muốn là trong một
cái web trang web của mình và học viên
mà mình sẽ đặt câu hỏi thì từ đó nó gọi
của nó em nhưng mà mình đang bị cái vấn
đề là nó nó xử lý rất là lâu. Mỗi lần
mình mình đặt câu hỏi ở trên cái trang
của mình thì gọi em rất là lâu. thì mình
nghĩ là không biết có phải là do mình
đang dùng cái MCB thì nó tệ hơn tại vì
lúc trước mình chưa chưa biết về cái CLI
của anh anh Trình mới nói thì không biết
là anh Trình với lại anh Minh có cái có
cái kinh nghiệm gì về cái hướng đó không
thì có thể tư vấn giúp mình được không
ạ?
Ờ
ra mình cũng không biết là cái nào nó
nhanh hơn cái nào, chỉ có biết là xài
LCP nó tốn tốn token hơn.
P nó bị tình trạng vài bữa nó cứ bắt log
in lại.
>> Đúng rồi, đúng rồi. Còn cái cái cái CLI
này lâu nay mình làm xong là mình không
thấy nó hỏi gì hết trơn á. Nó nó lưu
luôn cái user đó là nó xài
trên ATI Gravity thôi. Còn mình chưa
tích hợp nó vào thành cái chatbot ở trên
web mình chưa thử. Chưa thử chưa thử. Ờ
nó cũng là một cái ý nó cũng một cái ý
hay.
Tại vì mình muốn làm một cái trang về
cho
một cái khoa học về cho cộng đồng nhưng
mà nó nó thuần về tâm lý học hơn cho nên
nó sẽ không cần nhiều về cái về những
hình ảnh như giống one nhưng mà nó sẽ
dạng như một cái tư vấn ví dụ như về tâm
lý người ta gặp cái cái case nào đó thì
nó sẽ dùng kiến thức của trong mình đã
bơm cho nó rồi và nó trả lời ra cho cái
học viên.
Có nghĩa là em hiểu là anh đang tận dụng
cái nguồn của notebook em là một cái rá.
>> Ờ có thể coi như vậy mình mình cũng chưa
cũng đang bắt đầu muốn tìm hiểu thêm về
cái rá đó nhưng mà chưa chưa có điều
kiện để mình làm thì mình đang muốn FM
trước nhưng mà thấy có bạn nó chậm quá.
coi coi như là anh dùng nguyên cái
notebook anh đưa hết cái những cái dữ
liệu về liên quan đến tâm lý học kiểu
kiểu như vậy.
>> Xong sau đó anh tạo ra thành một cái
dạng chatbot anh share cho
>> Đúng rồi. Mình mình làm chung một trang
landing base của cái chương trình đấy.
>> Dạ. Xong rồi sẽ có một cái ờ đăng nhập
vào của từng từng user thì sẽ có cái cá
nhân hóa cho họ cũng có thể một vài cái
ý tưởng mà nãy giờ gamingfication cho họ
theo từng ngày họ vào họ học những cái
lý thuyết cơ bản như cái phần chính là
mỗi ngày họ sẽ có những cái cây series
của họ họ họ nhập vào thì cái con
chatbox đó nó phải link được những cái
hệ thống k thức của mình để nó trả lời
lại trên cái k thức đấy chứ không phải
là trả lời như một con JPT hay là JP9
bình thường bên ngoài mà k thức nó tùm
lum hết.
>> Ô cái đó em chưa ứng dụng.
>> Thật ra là cái chatbot mà dùng trực tiếp
thì đúng là dùng trên notebook em mình
tự custom theo cái như cái hướng của anh
Vũ vừa nói thì nó có em làm rồi nhưng mà
nếu mà để share để link với một cái
website đúng không anh đang link với một
cái ch
>> Đúng rồi đúng rồi link thì vì mình làm
được là trên website nó sẽ cho một cái
cái màn hình giống như là một chbox rồi.
>> Dạ
>> nhưng mà vấn đề Berment đang gặp rất
nhiều berment. Dạ
>> là có là bị đăng nhập hoài thì có lẽ là
để mình thử thử cái CLI nó có đỡ hơn cái
MCP không.
>> Cái cái cái đó thì đúng cũng chưa trải
nghiệm. Em cũng chưa làm tại vì nếu mà
làm chỉ làm chatbot thông thường còn nếu
mà làm qua như một cái cái BX giống như
ấy thì chưa
tại vì cái MCP đúng là cái lỗi của nó là
vẫn vì bị cứ cái cái cái performance của
nó hay out ra đó.
Ừ.
>> Ok. Thôi cái phần đó chắc phải trải
nghiệm thêm rồi. Phải phải phải. Dạ.
>> Dạ.
À trong nhóm mình không biết còn ai có
câu hỏi gì á với anh Trình không mọi
người?
đến đoạn này thì chắc có lẽ là mọi người
chắc cũng
anh trình ơi ở trong à cái chat room á
thì mọi người có để một cái link để à
feedback về cái buổi Zoom ngày hôm nay á
và ở trong đó có một câu hỏi về ví dụ
như là mình có muốn đăng có một cái khóa
để anh dạy làm cái này á thì em thấy em
có cái option đó có phải là anh có dự
định làm cái đó không ạ? Và có thể là
chia sẻ với mọi người nếu như mà anh có
dự định mở khỏe đó không ạ? Thank you an
cảm ơn anh.
>> Ờ thật ra thì anh cũng đang muốn thật ra
thì cái cái để làm một cái trang web như
thế này á hoặc là cái cái nhu cầu thành
ra anh đang cũng muốn tìm hiểu thêm thử
là mọi người tham gia ngày hôm nay là
mọi người có cái nhu cầu như thế nào.
Còn như đầu buổi anh chia sẻ rồi anh
không phải là dân chuyên nên có những
cái mình
chia sẻ với nhau là là là chia sẻ trên
cái kinh nghiệm của mình. Còn nếu như mà
trong một số trường hợp mà có các bạn có
nhu cầu mà các bạn cần phải ngồi mình
ngồi mình có thêm buổi nữa hay là như
thế nào đó kỹ hơn hoặc là nó sẽ đi vào
một cái cái cái cái phần xây dựng web
thôi chẳng hạn thì thì mình có thể mình
có thể ờ ngồi với nhau. Thì thật ra mình
sáng cũng có chia sẻ với với Minh là anh
em cũng đang dân amat mà đi chia sẻ mà
gọi là dạy đó thì không không tự tin
lắm. Nhưng mà nếu như mọi người cảm thấy
ngày hôm nay mọi người có nhiều cái ờ
học được, mọi người cảm thấy là cái bài
chia sẻ này nó có nó ổn, mọi người có
thể tiếp thu, có thể học được từ mình
thì mình sẵn sàng thôi. Tại vì thực ra
qua cái dự án này mọi người cũng thấy
rồi, mình là cái tâm thế là làm cộng
đồng đó, ra đường ở như thế nào chưa
biết nhưng mà cứ làm cái đã.
Ờ nếu mọi người có nhu cầu thì mọi người
cứ đi vào cái form mà mình cảm thấy là
mình mình phải đầu tư thêm thời gian để
mình có buổi chia sẻ nó nó phù hợp với
với nhu cầu của mọi người hơn thì mình
sẽ làm.
>> Gửi gửi lại cái link cho anh Minh ơi. Nó
trôi bên trên rồi anh.
>> Ok ok.
Cái cái chim
chim chim.
Dài dài này chắc có zoom ch nó ok mà
đúng không?
>> Nếu mà dài quá thì
bỏ qua bên doc đi.
>> Ừ. Rồi rồi
rồi. Thì như nãy mình có hứa thôi mình
bỏ vào trong cái cái cái cái cái folder
này luôn ha.
là mình sẽ chia sẻ cho mọi người một số
các cái
cái cái
skill ở trong đó có một cái skill là
mình mình học từ mình lụm của Minh giờ
mình chia sẻ lại thôi nha Minh nha
có chia sẻ gì thì cứ có làm đi bác ơi có
gì đâu
rồi coi như phần thưởng cho những bạn
ngồi lại tới cuối.
Mọi người
cho chàng tay đi. xe liền copy liền cho
chà m tay
>> gửi trái tim gửi gửi rồi nhiều rồi vô
ch
rồi chia sẻ trong này nó sẽ có a
hai cái skill
à hai cái bộ skill về
cái và cái test skill thì hai cái này là
nó dành cho là hai cái skill dành cho
thiết kế giao diện người dùng.
một cái skill viết chuyên nghiệp của
thầy thầy Tùng. Thầy Tùng
cũng chia sẻ khá là nhiều thì mình cũng
tải trên web của thầy thôi.
Và cái skill là đánh giá skill á là cái
skill này của thầy Minh Đỗ đó. Còn
marketing skill kia là những cái skill
mà nó liên quan tới
tới tới
viết bài rồi sale cho trang web rồi tất
cả mọi thứ liên quan tới marketing thì
nó nằm ở trong cái mình cũng có dùng đó
thì mình coi như là cái quà tặng nho nhỏ
cho mọi người ngồi tới ngày hôm nay là
có 50
trừ mấy ông ban tổ chức 55 người đó thì
gửi tặng mọi
Rồi cảm ơn B trình rất là nhiều, rất
vui. Hy vọng là
những cái skill này nó có ít với mọi
người.
Nhưng mà thật ra cũng không biết là mọi
người có đăng ký form hay không tới thời
điểm này. Nhưng mà mình hy vọng là mọi
người cứ đăng ký form á. Tại vì để bác
trình biết là mọi người thực sự có nhu
cầu đến đâu và biết đâu được thì có thể
là sẽ tổ chức thêm.
một buổi, hai buổi hay là như thế nào
đó. Nói chung là mình sẽ nắm được thông
tin
vọng của mọi người.
Rồi anh em nào có con 7 đến 10 tuổi
tạo học giùm nha.
Anh ơi cho em hỏi anh Trình hồi nãy em
có điền form rồi á nhưng mà trên đó chỉ
có số điện thoại tài khoản Zalo này nọ
nhưng mà em không có tài khoản Zalo thì
mấy anh chị sẽ gửi email hay sao ạ?
>> Nếu như mà có khoa học
>> em cứ có email đi Huyền.
>> Dạ em có để rồi ạ. Em cảm ơn ạ. Ừ. Có
inbox cho anh cứ nhắn qua hỏi anh cũng
được rồi anh nhắn lại cho
cho anh Trình.
>> Thank you anh Nên.
>> Ừ.
>> Rồi anh em còn hè mà có đi bảo tàng thì
đến thì cứ passw là học trò của anh
trình trình ra đón.
Thật ra thì mình ở đó thì mình quản lý
mấy bạn hướng dẫn viên với lại tham
quan, phục vụ khách tham quan nên mọi
người đến thì cứ
học trò passw học trò anh Trình anh
Trình chạy ra.
>> Tôi biết vậy hôm bữa tôi ở Đà Lạt tôi
xuống luôn.
>> Ủa tôi rủ không biết ông xuống chứ ông
chê tôi á. Ông ngồi với người đẹp, ông
chê người đẹp trai, ông ngồi người đẹp
gái không.
Ôi đi bảo tàng hoài luôn giờ mới biết.
Minh là vợ lo gì Minh mai mua vé
đêm nay Mai tới Nha Trang rồi
thiệt vô gọi gặp cho gặp thầy Trình là
thầy ra đón
cứ gặp mấy cô ảo dài nói cho em gặp thầy
Trình
>> nhưng mà Hải Dương học thấy là đợt này
sau này thay đổi thấy có nhiều cái hay á
>> nói không phải là
nhưng mà mình cũng đóng góp khá nhiều
trong cái những cái thay đổi với cái
trưng bày mới thì xuống từ ngày mà đi
làm bảo tàng hay tâm sự tí hay làm bảo
tàng thì mình đóng góp vào cái phần
thông tin rồi thiết kế cho bảo tàng cũng
khá nhiều về fanpage thì fanpage bảo
tàng đây h admin
toàn bộ những cái gì trên bả Phân và
tàng thì mình làm phụ trách
>> à
>> trên đin trên đủng
đây.
>> Dạ.
>> Nhưng mà ông nói chung là có một cái khu
vực mà mọi người có thể là thấy và chụp
hình những cái sinh vật biển
rất là rõ, rất là đẹp.
Đặc biệt là nếu mà có cô nào mà nếu mà
đi chừng vài người á thì nhờ một cô
thuyết trình á thì mình sẽ hiểu sâu hơn
về sinh vật biển.
>> Mời cô thuyết trình thôi nha. Đừng có
kêu anh Trình đi thuyết trình nha.
>> Rồi cảm ơn anh Trình rất nhiều. Chào mọi
người.
>> Rồi
>> ok bây giờ còn chắc có lẽ mọi người chắc
có lẽ là không có ấy nữa thì thôi chắc
là mình có chụp hình không Minh?
>> Dạ
>> Minh có chụ có chụp hình không?
Chắc lẽ
>> chụp cái hình đ chứ nhỉ?
>> Ờ chụp cái hình chia sẻ ngày lần đầu
tiên mình chia sẻ cái này với mọi người
thiệt sự luôn á. Ông Minh ổ ổng nói miết
rồi mà không dám nhận. Thật sự
>> nói hối hối quá trời hối luôn mà cứ hứa
với hẹn không.
Bạn tổ chức chụ hình đi. Phải phải tắt
cái xe. Phải tắt xe
>> tắt cái xe hả?
>> Dạ
>> tắt đi. Tắt đi tắt như thế nào? Tắt ở
đây. Stop stop
meeting nay chị đập chăng.
>> Cái này chị Hương nhanh lắm. Để chị
Hương.
>> Chị Hương là chị làm về cái gì vậy chị?
Chị cũng làm YouTube, chị cũng làm
YouTube luôn đó bác Trình ơi.
>> Thấy bữa học nào cũng thấy chị hết trơn
á. Giỏi thiệt chứ.
>> Ủng hộ Minh
>> dạ chư.
>> Đừng có nói ủng hộ đừng có nói ủng hộ
Minh mà chị là cao thủ trên cao thủ nữa
đó trình ơi.
>> Cao thủ giả Lâm.
>> Ngày xưa chị làm IT làm web application
out sin cho
>> Úi giời ơi đúng nghề luôn.
Thế chị ngồi đây em là múa rìu qua chị
được
à. Mọi người mở camera đi. Thả tim nha.
1 2 3 nha.
Rồi để chụp thêm tấm nữa tí nó chả video
cho mọi người luôn. Chứ đã thiệt chứ đi
học còn quay luôn cho cả lớp
>> rồi.
>> Bảo nhớ có chế độ đãi xài tool cho anh
nha Bảo nha.
>> Còn trang nữa nha anh em.
>> Nữa hả? Nhiều trang dữ vậy.
>> Trang nữa nhớ.
>> Ông bảo ổ chụp hình ổ đưa cái mặt ổ lên.
Ổng đưa mặt cũng lên không đẹp gì hết.
Làm bữa mấy bữa đưa cái mic đồ lên đẹp
quá. Nãy đặt
>> từ từ vẫn còn nữa. Bộ sao nhiều dữ trời.
Ba chang lặn hả? Chờ chút đi nha.
>> Đông quá vậy
>> trời ơi. Dự kiếm nay phải 300 anh em á
mà tôi bút show tới ái luôn mà sao bữa
nay chưa tới 100 anh em là
>> rồi xong rồi.
>> Rồi ok cảm ơn cả nhà.
>> Rồi cảm ơn chị.
>> Cảm ơn.
>> Biết ơn a anh Trình. Biết ơn anh Minh.
Biết ơn các anh chị.
>> Anh Trình tối nay ngủ ngon. Ờ có cần kết
nối thì đó mình có Facebook
>> à nãy gửi gửi Facebook lên chưa anh
Trình ha? Gửi lên chưa ta?
>> Ở đây còn có ai có muốn tâm sự gì á thì
zom chưa hết nha. Cứ
>> gửi vào zom gửi vào group Zalo á nó đỡ
bị trôi zom là xong.
>> Ok
>> luôn.
>> Trước khi tắt chương trình thì cho em a
xin phép gia đình bán phúc.
>> Ok. Ok anh Hữu Hàng.
>> Dạ. Thực ra thì bữa giờ khi mà kết nối
với cộng đồng của anh Minh á thì em cũng
tham gia được ba bốn lần zom. Thực ra
thì em cũng có tìm hiểu về anh Gravity.
Em cũng làm được vài cái website nhưng
mà nó không được hoàn thiện như của anh
a anh Trình.
Và hiện tại thì cũng đang theo đuổi để
tiến bộ hơn qua cái câu chuyện và cái
chương trình mà bữa giờ mà em học tập á.
Thực ra thì em thấy cái sự à
cái cái năng lượng mà chia sẻ của các
anh chị nó rất chi là bao dung. Cái tri
thức mà bây giờ ở xã hội mà để chia sẻ
nhiều như thế này nó cũng có ít ít người
rộng cái tâm như anh chị. Em rất chi là
biết ơn cái cái tinh thần cũng như là
cái tri thức của anh chị để chia sẻ đến
cộng đồng.
Đó là những gì em muốn gửi đấy. Chúc cả
nhà lung bình an và trí tuệ. Dạ vâng. Em
xin hết.
>> Vâng.
>> Dạ. Cảm ơn anh.
>> Vâng. Rồi vất rất là cảm ơn anh Hữu
Hàng. không biết là à anh a có cái điểm
mạnh gì thì Minh chưa biết tại vì cũng
chưa được dịp giao lưu nhiều nhưng mà hy
vọng rằng á là trong những buổi zom sẽ
có dịp được mời anh Hữu Hàng à cùng cộng
đồng của Minh cũng như là với mọi người
ở đây chia sẻ qua những cái buổi zom này
>> dạ vâng em rất là em ơi
>> làm được cái gì em giấu đi chứ ông Minh
không thấy là ổ lôi ra mệt lắm
>> đang lôi thêm bạn nữa cũng ứng dụng cho
bên mảng giáo viên mà tiếng Nhật nữa kia
kìa.
Tiếng Nhật hẳn hôi nhá.
Bạn đó là cũng bị lôi lôi kéo kéo mà bạn
đó nói em ngại lắm, em ngại lắm. Nói
ngại thì em lôi cho bằng được thôi mà.
Ok. Thì nói vui như vậy thôi để cho cả
nhà mình giải trí tí xíu. Nhưng mà mình
hình dung ra có những cái thật ra những
buổi chia sẻ này nó rất là quý mọi
người. Ờ tại vì Minh cũng a cái gì không
cái gì nói thì nó cũng có có qua thì
cũng phải có lại. Thì thật ra nó có
những cái những buổi nào chuyên sâu và
đòi hỏi mà mình phải đi sát xa với nhau
á thì chắc chắn là mình không thể nào
ngồi một buổi này hay là hai buổi mà
chúng ta có thể giải quyết được hết vấn
đề. Cho nên bắt buộc mình phải có cái sự
đồng hành đúng không cả nhà? Còn lại á
thì những cái buổi mà chia sẻ về cơ bản
là thí dụ như ngồi với nhau hai tiếng 3
tiếng như thế này á thì nó rất là chi là
thoải mái với mình hay là với anh Trình
hay là với mọi người.
Thậm chí mình trước ngày trước luôn á
nếu mà anh Hữu Hàng thì chắc mới vào
mình không biết nhưng mà có những cái
đợt trước à chắc cái thời điểm mà trước
Tết nữa thì phải á thì mình cứ thứ ba
thứ ba hàng tuần là mình sẽ có một cái
buổi Zoom online thứ ba hàng tuần luôn
định kỳ. Đó là mình chia sẻ, mình cứ
chia sẻ liên tục mà lúc đó chắc bá bác
trình cũng chưa chưa biết đến mình nữa.
Thì là về antiravity là đời đầu à mình
gần như là lên chém gió không biết đúng
hay sai cứ lên chém gió. Tối thứ ba phải
nói luôn là lúc đó là gần như là
ờ biết gì cho đó luôn chứ không có gọi
là ấy luôn. Tà từ landing bed rồi đến
làm ra cái này cái kia. Nhưng mà rồi nó
cũng cạn kiệt ý tưởng. Cái thứ nhất, cái
thứ hai là mình cũng phải có những cái
định hướng khác đó. Nhưng mà gần đây thì
bắt đầu mình cũng hy vọng là có anh em
kết nối với nhau và mọi người kết nối
lại với nhau á thì chia sẻ nó được nhiều
hơn. Cho nên mình cũng thấy là ngoài cái
việc mà mình tự chia sẻ như vậy thì cũng
hy vọng là những anh em có mặt ở trong
cộng đồng á ai biết cái gì thì mọi người
đóng góp một tí đó lên chia sẻ cho nó
vui cho có sâm tụ tí xíu.
Đó. Vâng. Vâng. Thật ra là kiến thức ở
bên ngoài á thì mọi người chắc có lẽ thì
đã học rồi hay là tham gia những cái
buổi zom nó cũng không ít đâu hoặc là
những cái cộng đồng khác chia sẻ nó cũng
rất là nhiều nhưng mà qua những cái buổi
chia sẻ vậy á thì mình được cái là ngồi
lại với nhau tương tác trực tiếp nè cho
giao lưu nè ví dụ như anh Vũ có những
cái câu hỏi mình thấy rất là chi rất là
hay luôn nhưng mà cứ mỗi lần mà anh em
đang vừa trao đổi cái hết zom
ông trình ổng nói là hôm nay làm cái gì
làm phải cho 3 tiếng N
đó để em coi lại cái cái record của Khoa
hôm trước. Anh Vũ mới vừa hỏi xong cái
Đức luôn
em. Hôm nay mới ông cho tôi 3 tiếng đ
hai tiếng ông Vũ không hỏi.
>> À thật ra á là trong tuần này nhá, trong
tuần này là Minh có cũng có một cái dự
định nữa là sẽ chia sẻ tiếp về anti
Gravity nếu như mà ấy. Nhưng mà thật ra
lại hôm nay đã là thứ năm rồi nhưng mà
Anti Gravity cái mình dự định chia sẻ là
nó có liên quan đến cái phiên bản Anti
Gravity 1 là 2.0 không và phiên bản IDER
cũng như là sự kết hợp với Obsidian như
thế nào để quản lý tổ chức dữ liệu cho
nó hiệu quả. Ờ cái cách mà chuyển đổi
giữa hai cái nền tảng kiểu kiểu như vậy
đó ID và 2.0 và kết nối với cái obsidian
à làm sao cho nó hiệu quả. Thì cái này
nó cũng là một trong những cái mà về
quản lý dữ liệu thôi chứ nó cũng không
có gì cao siêu mà mình không đi sâu vào
cách là tạo skill hay là cách ái đâu
nhưng mà cái cách tổ chức dữ liệu đại
khái là như vậy thì nhưng mà trong tuần
này chắc có lẽ là không kịp nữa rồi tại
vì hôm nay cũng thứ năm mà ngày mai thứ
sáu thì đang còn có một cái kế hoạch nữa
mà trong tuần này thì cũng đã có một
buổi chia sẻ của anh Khoa với Bắc Trình
đây rồi. Chắc có lẽ mình phải delay lại
tí xíu nha anh em.
Bớt thôi. Học tuần ba buổi chữ đâu mà
đầu đâu mà chưa?
>> Ông trình ổng làm về nhà nghiên cứu nhà
bác học ổng học nhiều quá rồi.
>> Anh Vũ tối nay có gì hay không anh Vũ?
Ờ cảm ơn. Nói chung hôm nay hôm nay học
rất là hay. Cái đầu tiên là như nãy mình
nói mình cho thử cái cách CLI ở của
Notbook nó khác với MCP.
Hi vọng là nó sẽ cải thiện được nhiều
thứ ha. Còn về mặt cái trang web của anh
trình thì nó quá tuyệt vời rồi. Lần
trước mình đ cũng đã nghe một cái bữa
của Minh có đề cập rồi cứ vào thử cho
thằ con đó các bạn. Thì nó thì thấy nó
rất là thích nó là là tuyệt vời. Còn hồi
nãy mình cũng tín đặt câu hỏi tại vì anh
Trình cũng nói là làm toàn bộ trên 1.0
thì mình nghĩ là nếu mà 2.0 thì nó sẽ
rút gắn được một số thứ thời gian xử lý
nhiều hơn với trình nhì Minh nhị.
Ông ch nói với mình nói mình tôi không
thích 2.0
vì nó sub action nó làm hết rồi tôi
không biết nó làm cái gì hết trơn á.
>> Không mình bấm ra phía bấm chi tiết nó
vẫn show bên phải ra cho mình coi nghe
được
>> nhưng mà nó tự làm hết cái mình không
biết là mình nó chạy đến cái gì rồi nên
thôi thôi tôi không có chơi
>> anh Vũ anh Vũ hiểu không? Kiểu nhưng mà
ổng vừa làm ổng muốn vừa coi cái đám
lính á là à nó phải ra được cái gì. Còn
cái này lính lính nó là đúng rồi. Lính
nó làm hết rồi. Subion có nghĩa là nó
automation gần như là nó chạy hết luôn.
Hậ ổ
>> thật ra nếu mà mình có một chủ đề mà
mình cũng đang vật lộn thì mình cái đề
xuất thử thì nếu anh em nào có kinh
nghiệm chia sẻ tức là chính là cái chủ
đề mà nếu mà dùng semini á dùng cái
native á thì nó rất là ổ. Thật ra thì
tất nhiên là cũng là lỗi của người dùng
nhưng mà dù mình có đã thử mình rào bằng
skill, rào bằng ru rồi nhưng mà cùng một
cái cái plan đó mà mình chạy bằng codex
với lại chạy bằng thằng thì nó ra hai
kết quả khác nhau hoàn toàn và nó nó báo
mình đi ngồi sửa cũng chết chết bỏ luôn.
Thì thì nếu như anh em có kinh nghiệm mà
để fích cái đó thì mình nghĩ cái đó nó
rất là giá trị cho những anh em mới bắt
đầu xài xài antiravity mà đặc biệt là là
xài bản của Zemini.
Ý anh là ý anh là sao?
Cái việc lên plan nè. Nếu bình thường
mình cũng dùng mình cũng tải cái bộ
skill của
clit skill về. Ví dụ có những skill là
skill rồi c rồi fit gì đó cùng cái đấy
nhưng mà khi mình mình dùng cái đó cho
một cái nhu cầu của mình cho cùng một
nhu cầu cho với với cái code cũng dùng
thôi nha chứ không phải là codex
>> và cùng cái đấy chều chạy cho ID cũ lẫn
cái 2.0 không mà mình gọi cái native
agent tức là thằng thằng á thì thằng
thường xuyên là nó sẽ bị ẩu, kết quả ra
nó sẽ lỗi hoặc là mình copy mình mình
soạn một cái skill là gọi là tham vấn
giữa hai bên. Tức là trước khi mình mình
đập approve cho nó chạy cái plan đó thì
mình yêu cầu nó soạn một cái prom mô tả
về cái đấy xong mình copy cái prom đó
mình quăng cho codex thì codex nó nó
detect ra rất nhiều cái lỗi trong cái
plan của thằng kia. Xong mình khi mình
quă quăng ngược ra lại cho thằng thằng J
nó sửa thì nó phải tốn đến ba b round
thì mới đến cái mức mình đọc mình thấy
là là ổn để có thể chạy được. Thay vì
code thì ngay cái bước đầu tiên mình
mình gọi cái skill là ví dụ CK plan thì
nó đã ra một cái bảng và mình mình đánh
giá là nó nó ổn hơn hoặc trong quá trình
nó thực thi cái play nó cũng vậy.
Tại vì thì mình cũng có đọc cũng nhiều
forum thì tất nhiên là cũng có nhiều
người họ chê theo phong trào nhưng mà
thật sự là mình thấy là cũng có nhiều
người họ phân tích đúng tức là cái cách
phát triển của JBI nó không không quá
chuyên về code agent so với Corex với
lại là clop
thì cũng muốn nếu mình có một cái chủ đề
về cái đó thì anh em có kinh nghiệm hoặc
là có cái cái trải nghiệm hơn thì có thể
chia sẻ thêm cho mình với cộng đồng
>> cái của anh á là nó liên quan tới cái
gọi là cái cục thì nếu mà nó dính tới
cái model thì nó lại liên quan tới cái
phần toen
token và cái memory của cái model đó.
Thì giống như là ví dụ như anh xài cái
con cloud đi, cloud đi thì nó sẽ có rất
nhiều con. Ví dụ như connect con opus
con
blue mới con fat blue nó mới có thì mỗi
con đó đó thì nó được cấp một cái lượng
màum token nó xử lý và cái memory nó xử
lý nó nó nó khác nhau thì nó quyết định
cái việc
là cái độ phức tạp hoặc là cái lượng
thông tin. Nếu như mà anh sử dụng một
cái con mà nó cái lượng cái token nó
thấp á mà để xử lý một cái vấn đề mà nó
vượt quá cái khối lượng token của nó đó
thì nó vẫn trả lời cho mình. Tuy nhiên
để trả lời được cho anh thì nó sẽ sử
dụng một cái cơ chế là nó thay vì nó đi
nó phải làm chi tiết nó cô đọc từng bước
chi tiết thì nó sẽ giả định và nó sẽ
>> đúng rồi mình bị nó nó bị suy suy luận
quá nhiều những cái giải đ
>> ừ
>> nó nó sẽ cố tình gọi là nó có một cái từ
khóa là hallucinate
>> thì cái hallucinate nó nó sẽ tựa đặt ra
và nó sẽ tự chế ra thay vì nó đi kiểm
chứng thì cái đó là do nếu như anh gặp
trường hợp như vậy và anh cần phải sử
dụng anh anh anh sử dụng con đó anh muốn
sử dụng một cái con model thấp mà trả
lời cho cái công việc nó phức tạp thì
anh phải xé nhỏ cái công việc đó ra
thành nhiều cái phần nhỏ thì nó mới trả
lời cho anh nó chính xác giống như là em
nói đơn giản nè em nói đơn giản mọi
người dễ hình dung tại vì ai ở đây cũng
làm content thì sẽ hình dung ra được là
để mà viết một cái content thì nó nó sẽ
phải có một cái tại sao mình phải làm
outline, mình không làm nó vẫn viết
được.
>> Ừ.
>> Nên nếu mà mình làm out với content dài
thì có thể là mình sẽ viết một phần,
phần một xong rồi mình mới viết phần hai
thì như vậy nó sẽ giảm thiểu cái vị size
stop khi mà mình viết ảnh luôn từ đầu
đến đua.
Thì cái đó nó nó
sẽ quay trở lại là cái con quay trở lại
là cái model anh đang sử dụng á đó thì
nó sẽ trả lời cái vấn đề mà anh đang bị
là bị ảo giác cái con cái con mod nó trả
lời nó hơi bị ẻm.
>> Cảm ơn chị. Các chị nói th nào đúng thì
thì tầm mình chỉ đang so sánh cho là
cùng một cái đề bài nó nó tương đối là
đơn giản chứ chưa đến nói những cái bài
toán phức tạp thì chấp nhận phức tạp thì
mình phải xài cloud
ust rồi nhưng mà ví dụ mình start một
cái cái configation mới tức là chưa bị
cái vấn đề về về context Windows luôn nó
cũng đã có những cái giống như chị nói
hallucination ví dụ nó lười đọc đọc
cospace nó lười đọc doc của mình dù là
mình đã đã chỉ định rồi nhưng mà nó đọc
nó đọc lướt lướt lướt lướt qua xong nó
tự nó giả định là những cái hàm khác
cũng tương tự tương tự như vậy. Thì thì
cái này mình mình cái cái ý của chị thì
mình cũng đang thử mình chia nhỏ ra hoặc
là mình sẽ nhắc nó nhiều hơn. Nhưng mà ý
mình đang nói là là phải chăng là nó là
cái coi như cái bản chất của con Gemini
nó bị cái đó so với những con Codex hay
là hay là close mà dù chưa phải là cái
bản mới nhất mạnh nhất của CL thì mình
đã thấy nó đã nó đã tốt hơn rất nhiều.
Ít bị những cái size đó hơn.
Đúng rồi. Cái này thì
DN em chỉ xài thứ nhất là thôi. Thì em
thấy rằng là cái DVN á nó cái cái LM của
nó chắc chắn là nó sẽ không bằng ờ cái
con clot rồi. Tại vì
ờ mặc dù là có thể là trên bề mặt nó
công bố là như thế tuy nhiên là về mặt
thực tế sử dụng thì em thấy nó không
bằng và cái cách trả lời của nó cũng sẽ
không có
có bằng các bằng như con lot. Con lot
thì do ừ cái phần chi phí thì nó khá khá
tốn so với anh em. Tuy nhiên thì
nếu như mà mình
cái công việc đó nó quan trọng, cái công
việc đó nó mang lại cái cho mình một cái
khoản chi phí hay khoản thu nhập rồi thì
em nghĩ là nên cân nhắc. Và nếu như mà
mình xài liên quan tới những cái công
việc mang lại thu nhập cho mình á thì
nên mua tài khoản chính hãng.
Bởi vì sao? Bởi vì cái tài khoản chính
hãng thì nó giống như một cái con LM á
mà nó xài một thời gian thì nó cái
memory của nó, cái mức độ mà nó hiểu
mình hoặc là tất cả những cái gì mình
build trên cái con đó đó sẽ là tài sản
giá trị hơn rất nhiều. Ờ và gần như là
nó là tài sản luôn á. mà mình ví dụ như
mình không biết cách backup, mình không
biết cách đưa lên GitHub backup thì ừ
những cái tài khoản mà mua mua ví dụ như
Cloudy ở ngoài nó bán rẻ hơn một chút.
Thực ra thì ừ đối với các ví dụ như
Gemini thì cái giá chênh lệch nhiều hoặc
là CH CVT chên lệch nhiều nhưng mà giá
Cloudi thì nó chên lệch ít lắm nhưng mà
nó khả năng mà nó bị quét tài khoản là
rất là cao. mà qué tài khoản rồi mọi
người mới thấy là giống như mình có một
cái máy tính cái xong rồi tự nhiên nó bị
à bị mất máy tính á cái cảm giác nó giảm
vậy á. đó thì
em khuyên chân thành nên mua tài khoản
chính hãng và mua tài khoản chính hãng
thì mình cũng đang góp phần cho công ty
nó phát triển tốt hơn để nó cung cấp
dịch vụ tốt hơn và Cloudi nó cập nhật
tính năng và mọi thứ cực kỳ nhanh
và cái tốc độ nó làm thì nó đúng là xứng
đáng
cho em chia sẻ thêm cái ý kiến của em ở
chỗ này. Em thật ra về cái đầu tiên là
cái ý của anh Vũ thì em hiểu thật ra nếu
mà đem so sánh giữa một cái đề bài này
ra á mà giữa Codex hay là đưa cho ông An
Davity làm á thì đến thời điểm này thì
hay là clot thì đúng là nếu mà đưa đề
bài theo kiểu đó thì gần như là cái phần
thắng mà nó gọi là viết ra một cái cái
ứng dụng á thì chắc có lẽ là cái ông
Codex hay là cái ông Clot á thì chắc ông
đứng đầu rồi.
Ờ nói nói cơ bản là nói vậy nhanh lẹ đi
chứ ổng lập cái FL ổng làm luôn ổng
không có kiểu mà bị ấy đâu như cái ông ừ
Germin ở trong antiravity nhưng mà nói
đi thì cũng phải nói lại à đó là những
người mà anh em ví dụ như anh anh Vũ hay
là những chị như chị Hương thì hiện nay
chị đang sử dụng bản clot 200 đô một
tháng luôn rồi mà cái đó thì tôi chịu
thua
>> nghèo lắm chị Hương ơi. Đó cái đó thì em
chịu thua
đó nhưng mà mà nhưng mà cũng phải nói
thêm đó bởi nói đi thì phải nói lại đi.
Nhưng mà tại sao đến thời điểm này mình
bản thân mình mình vẫn dùng anti gravity
và vẫn tạo ra những cái bộ công cụ, vẫn
tạo ra những cái bộ skill. Mình không
dám nói là mình chuẩn chỉ nhưng anh em
mà lướt lên những cái trang Facebook của
mình hoặc là trước đó nữa những cái
group thì mình xin thưa luôn là những
cái skill mình tạo ra từ tất cả là anti
Gravity hết và mình đem bán luôn mình
đưa đưa đi thương mại được à để mà mà
anh em sử dụng luôn và vẫn chuẩn chỉ các
kiểu. Thì mình quay lại cái câu chuyện
và mình đã có một cái bài chia sẻ luôn
là trong cách đây chắc khoảng tuần hai
tuần thôi. Đó là về cái skill văn bản
đảng à
nghị định văn bản đảng số 05. Số 05 đúng
rồi. Giữa do cái đợt đó là mới thay đổi
văn bản và vừa rồi mình có share cho một
số anh em. Thì khi mà làm sửa đổi cái
skill đó, cập nhật cái skill chú. Sau
khi mà cập nhật mình bắt đầu thử cùng
một nội dung, cùng một cái skill đó,
cùng một cái đề bài đưa ra luôn. bỏ vào
trong đó thêm hai cái file quyết định
thay đổi nghị định ABC các kiểu là file
PDF bảng gốc mình đưa cho bên một cái
con clot mình đang xài bản clot roll đọc
lại cái skill cũ đó là văn bản đảng và
một cái là đó là bên Cloudro nha là mày
hãy cập nhật dựa trên hai file PDF này
thông tin nghị định yêu cầu sửa đổi bổ
sung chuyển đổi qua số 05 thì cái đó là
clot nó làm rồi lại tiếp tục mình bên
này đứng ở bên nền tảng là Gravity yêu
cầu cũng làm tương tự cũng đề bài đặt ra
như vậy. Đọc cái thư mục cái skill đó số
skill cũ rồi phân tích đi phân tích hai
file PDF đi là nội dung này nè yêu cầu
sửa đổi văn bản đảng cập nhật lại cho
tao hết thì sau khi nó lập cái FL nó làm
A BC các kiểu quy trình đọc OCR rồi đọc
ABC để phân tích cái nội dung trong file
PDF sau đó nó cập nhật lại. Cuối cùng
sao? Cuối cùng mình quăng cái hai thằng
đó cho kiểm tra chéo nhau. Thằng clot
đọc lại skill của antiravity
đã hoàn tất thì nó đọc cái bản mà bản
final á. Nó đọc xong nó nói bản này của
mày hoàn hảo hơn bản của tao.
Anh anh anh em mà không tin á coi lại
trên Facebook. Em có chụp hình em chia
sẻ từng khung hình một luôn mà. Và cuối
cùng nó nói nó phải nhận lỗi là tao đã
bỏ sót những điểm này ở trong văn bản
gốc.
file PDF là tao đã bỏ sót. Còn cái bảng
của mày là ra đúng những cái này chỉ duy
nhất là có một cái lỗi nhỏ là bị thiếu
nhưng lỗi đó không đáng kể.
Đó thì ở đây mình không có nói là thằng
nào đúng thằng nào thằng nào mạnh các
kiểu nhưng anh em mà làm nhiều anh em mà
đi kiểm tra và cái kiểm tra chéo nữa thì
lúc này RCK thì anh em mới thấy là lúc
đó mình đăng trên cái diễn đàn ờ của
mình hay là kênh bên bên bên bên một số
cái cộng đồng khác thì lúc đó có một vài
anh em cũng có ý kiến luôn thật sự là
con clot nó vẫn có những cái điểm bị hạn
chế của nó cho nên mình đừng bao giờ
mình à đánh giá theo cái góc nhìn của
mình là mình khẳng định nó tốt 100% Mà
mình luôn luôn rằng tự tin rằng nó làm
đúng 100% mà không cần rock nha. Coi
chừng á
>> không nó vẫn
nợ c tất nhiên là con này phải rck tuy
nhiên là chị thấy cái tốc độ phát triển
mà tốc độ mà cải tiến của con Clou nó
cực kỳ nhanh. Có nghĩa là có thể là thời
điểm đó em test nó như thế nhưng mà thời
điểm bây giờ nó cũng có thể khác.
>> Em mới test cách đây hai tuần chứ mấy
>> khác rồi em. Em đang sử nó ra một cái
con
>> em đang sử dụng lúc đó là con 4.8 rồi
còn đâu nữa. Còn cái con Facebook thì
khỏ khỏi nói rồi. Con đó là con con mới
nhất thì không dám nói rồi. Nhưng mà
mình dung cái câu chuyện là giữa một con
trả phí cực kỳ cao, giữa một con là 3.5
flash một con rất là rẻ tiền.
>> Ôi cái này mình nói không biết khi nào
giải quyết xong đâu.
>> Đúng cho nên nó đừng không ý em không
muốn nói là cái nào nó hơn cái nào nhưng
mà cần là phải có rock nếu như mình làm.
Thực ra giống như em là khỏe nhất nè.
Nghèo có xài có bằng con thôi. Không cần
phải biết không phải so sánh gì hết trơn
á.
Không tại vì cái mình đang làm á là nó
liên quan đến văn bản nhà nước cho nên
nó cần phải có rock chứ còn thật ra mà
làm những cái dạng công cụ mà kiểu như
là như website bác trình đi. Ví dụ như
mình về cảm quan hoặc là dựa vào kinh
nghiệm là mình đã thấy nó đúng chưa?
Mình làm thấy nó ok chưa là như vậy là
mình tự quyết luôn. Nhưng còn về mà
những cái dạng mà văn bản hành chính và
những cái skill thựt ra mình còn một số
skill ví dụ như ngày hôm qua hôm kia mới
share một cái bộ skill thuế thu nhập cá
nhân mình mới share cũng là làm trên
anti gravity từ đầu đến giờ mình vẫn là
anti gravity mà thôi đó
>> anti là trống không trống đối không anh
Vũ share cho em cái trang web của anh Vũ
anh Vũ ơi
>> ăn ti là trống
Cho em xem cái trang web của anh Vũ nha.
>> Anh Vũ làm bên lĩnh vực gì em cũng quên
hỏi. Bữa giờ anh Vũ có nói mà
>> bật mí biết mí anh Vũ ơi.
>> À à để cái mình cũng đang mới bắt đầu
làm nhưng mà cũng giao diện ngày nọ cũng
còn chán lắm cho nên để cứ cứ cứ share
thử anh em góp ý thêm cho dự án của cộng
đồng chia sẻ về các chương trình đào tạo
miễn phí. Ui giời cứ cộng đồng anh em cứ
bứt anh em xem thoải mái anh ơi. Bọn em
cộng đồng hết rồi rồi. Cảm ơn mấy anh em
nhiều.
>> Anh anh đưa lên trên cái group chat này
đi. Tại vì hình như là bác trình không
có group bên kia đâu. Anh Vũ ơi.
>> Group nào có group nữa hả?
>> Không tại vì
ông trình ổng ổ ổng kỵ em ổ qua group đó
chứ không phải
>> nào chê.
nó giận chứ cái group đó là group mà từ
ngày mới mới bước chân tập tảnh vào đi
chơi rồi lập ra thì thì tới bây giờ thì
có anh Vũ thì vẫn còn trong đó đây
anh anh gửi trong cái ô chat này thôi
anh Vũ ý là em đang nói ô chat của Zoom
á
>> à à
>> dạ dạ
>> nó còn có 5 phút nữa anh là hết giờ nữa
rồi
>> ờ đúng rồi đó
>> à xin là lên đăng ký
đang dùng một cái máy khác nên phải
chuyển qua.
>> Ok. Để anh gửi lại
gửi anh Chiến nha. Ok.
>> Chiến này anh Chiến là phải đi dạy đi
chứ học gì nữ anh Chiến ơi.
>> Ông này bên nhóm mình luôn hả? Đúng
không?
>> Anh Chiến trong nhóm mình thấy cũng làm
sản phẩm cho em cho út cháu nhiều lắm.
Thấy nghe không? Anh Chiến ơi.
>> Ôi đi ngủ. Cảm ơn anh chị gửi cái link
của cái cái web mình mới làm cũng làm
cũng đưa lên chưa chưa làm về database
gì hết cho nên là
>> dạ
>> chủ yếu là mới làm lên page để cho mọi
người đăng ký cái chương trình tổ chức
tại Hà Nội với Hồ Chí Minh thôi dự án
cộng đồng thôi
>> rồi mình đang link một số cái artifact
của bên em đưa vào cái nội dung
>> à
>> đó mình mới làm được cái phần à thanh
toán dùng qua cổng xe bay á tức là có
cái chi phí mà hậu cần để mua đồ ăn này
nọ các thứ thì thì mình cũng dùng
antivity thì nó nó nó tư vấn mình dùng
cái xe bay cũng hay. Em em đang muốn gắn
vô em chưa biết làm sao đây. Bữa tôi chỉ
ông bữa tôi chỉ cái CP gắn tôi chỉ rồi
mà
>> nó đơn giản nhất á.